elle a aujourd'hui c'est sûr aujourd'hui
c'est sûr il va se passer il va se
passer des choses parce que hier
finalement fab
on a été un peu c'était la déception on
a là un petit peu dans web on écoute ça
va c'était pas les bars passionnante
mais bon y ont un animal favori pour les
rapides
du coup le train rapide s'est pas non
plus nouvelles choses
non non c'est sûr mais c'était plus us
et sur le fait je voulais revenir sur
sur le fait que voilà on a passé trois
heures pour voir de la pleutre haddad
partout quoi
ouais bah écoute bon aujourd'hui moins
ceux des parties rapides voire des blitz
voir des trucs comme ça donc bien oui
oui oui non aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ça va être bien il va y
avoir des rapides puis de toute façon
quoi qu'il en soit fin juin au bout d'un
moment tu fait que des nuls y aura
l'armageddon forcément la cadence ultime
quoi tomber quoi ton ça y est ça marche
déjà aujourd'hui ça marche
ah bah ça m'était trêve était très
énervé donc il est passé par là et il
m'a dit oui je m'en occupe tout de suite
le mans series est criard deux heures
après mais bon je vais pas dire le nom
de la personne qui n'avait pas fait le
boulot quoi mais je sais qui c'est quoi
alors il m'a appelé j'ai réglé le
problème
un bon bah là personne n'en a plus de
maison vit sous un pont ouais et même
journal ait partie qu'au bout d'un
moment on s'en fout aussi car ça casse
sa vie nous avons dans notre projet non
mais très heureux quand votre travail
c'est tout ce qui nous est un as en face
à nous on est heureux de tous la banque
rhône-alpes et gêne depuis le début et
j'ai quand même mis fable le petit
échiquier à droite comme ça il ya
toujours il ya le temps de live le truc
tout partout comme ça on est partout et
on peut on peut voir un
est ce que tu préfères les ch'tis guéri
ouvert avait lassé des questions après
le chat peut voter on s'en fout en fait
je sais pas vraiment comment changer de
grille avait enfin si je sais mais ça
demande de refaire tout le set up là un
bon alors on regarde glisse très bien on
est gris quoi ah non il écrit fernand a
maigri et bien une odeur de sainteté à
jouer hongrie donc ils sont gris ils ont
fait quoi là r non ils ont perdu mais
c'est un match pour rien parce qu'on
gagne qu'on perd on va semer ont été
éliminés quoi qu'il arrive
du coup ça ne change pas d'efforts à des
chèques voilà c'est ça bon bah j'ai
quand même été courageux d'aller voir le
match bomba palmarès on est double
allez des mecs qui sont blessés pour un
match je sais pas qui du coup bas -
qu'important quoi bon ou moins graves
mais hamouma comment aller à moi il est
pas mauvais pas non aux yeux du manager
il nous avait sortis des buts quoi
faille était là on se dit ça aurait été
cool de l'avoir pour jouer des matchs de
ligue 1 quoi bon voilà non en fait tu
vois tu le fais jouer pour un match que
toute façon tu peur qui sert à rien
battus à du troisième de sa poule d'uefa
mener deux éliminés en fait on s'en fout
battez blessés voilà allez hop à ce qui
était dégoûté au rugby c'était les
ospreys ce contre le racing bronze et
ils ont tout donné dans la moitié de
leur équipe qui est blessé bon ils sont
en sueur entrée 30 secondes de jeu ils
se prennent un carton rouge
parce qu'en ce moment ça commence mal et
donc voilà ils ont fait quand même appel
parce que le mec fays j'ai juste en
l'air et sept joueurs du racing qui
feinte qui plonge sur la chaussure de
l'autre quoi ouais mais non ils ont dit
non bafa c'est tombé sur sa tête c'est
pas de chance mais même si la tête qui
va vers le pied en fait t'es quand même
responsable
donc je ne sais plus cinq ou six
semaines de suspension mais ils sont en
surface ils ont déjà plus de joueurs et
en bleu se met aux fourneaux en fait
valoir brice haute voix et enfin tu y
mets un peu son pied ferme devant mais
pour regarder les clips quoi ben mes
questions du coup si tu joues à quatre
pattes
est ce que tu fais faire des rouges à
tout le monde tu vas tu après tout les
pieds de tout le monde bomba est ce que
tout se prend des rouges tu avais
vraiment l'action est un peu bizarre
sais pas si tu l'as vu un cette action
n'est pas le joueur qui saute il met son
pied pour se retenir pas le joueur du
racing qui est complètement en retard
mais du coup sa tête va sur le pied mais
je leur fais tu t'es juste en retard
lefa le ballon fabriqué encore en l'air
fatah rien à faire là en fait et en plus
tu fais mal tomber le mec parce que du
coup le vans la de la tête tombe dans le
pied le make up tombe mal puisque tu vas
tu la bouscule en l'air mais c'est quand
même fin naturelle depuis hier donc le
bon nom mais en fait tu devrais
apprendre à sauter les pieds au sol ce
serait beaucoup mieux ta pâte à pas de
chance non mais des fois c'est un
parfois c'est un petit peu dur ces
règles là d'un autre côté il faut aussi
dire qu'il ya pas y'a pas longtemps
chaque instant fédéral une fédérale 2 il
ya un mec qui est mort quand même parce
qu'il y en a deux qui ont fait un double
plaquage à l'épaule sur les côtes mais
non cathédrale et non non non ils ont
ils sont venus
deux à l'épaule tu vois les landais paul
les voisins ils ont dégommé ils ont un
peu comme les voitures que tu es
apparemment ce que disait le père du
joueur c'est que l'ex aille au pénal
parce que c'était un des plaquages
dangereux volontaire mes images a faim
c'est quand je suis dans l'homicide quoi
fin à un moment donné à présent mais
qu'un prix carton rouge
ouais mais pas de chance cartons rouges
ont mal garé au moins son équipe a gagné
sa main droite
ouais non le père du joueur j'avais dû
me voulait bah oui porté plainte pour
homicide involontaire
non mais c'est beau en fait ni mort
carton rouge oui l'esprit de l'ovalie
comme nous tous non c'était donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils qui surprotègent un petit
peu les joueurs bon allez mvl je crois
en toi à 15h30 je dois filer donc merci
de des grains ce look et opal of a le
truc c'est que ça va en fait ça va être
terminé à tu verras pas tout le mal est
fait la deuxième partie commence à 15h30
déjà mais bon tu auras la première après
maxi avec les blancs la presse tu penses
quoi aujourd'hui une berlinoise de 4,5
web après mac soit il peut faire du
fossé cadre aussi une italienne soit il
retourne là bas rhinoise
parce que là il a pu bosser en plus
ligne icloud et c'est trop s'est vite
pour peut-être peuvent doit changer
je sais pas tout cas on est confiant
quand même
bah oui on est confiante toujours on est
confiant et a tu donnes donc toi tu
donné hier 100% mejia plus sérieusement
tu donnes du cadmium indigence 90-95 n'y
a pas de raison ouais écrasant favori
aujourd'hui 1 mais bon il suffit d'une
gaffe il suffit d'une étincelle
hippolyte qui bonjour à tous ça va le
faire aujourd'hui bah écoute
ouais oui oui oui ça devrait le faire
milliken mme albanel qui très confiant
il a battu carlson en rapide bliss la
semaine dernière papito pinet n'est
qu'une formalité
non mais tu as ça me fait d'ailleurs
pourquoi mais tu ne jouais pas
non mais oui oui faut ça me fait penser
à des matchs de premier tour
tu as ta nadal contre un mec sur
terre-battue tu vois pas pourquoi il
devrait pas gagner quoi
une pub apte à une pub bras ballants
après une série la purge d'ailleurs ah
ouais ils le peuvent c'est souvent moi
aussi me conseille souvent mais en fait
moi ça me saoule séduit parce qu'en plus
je lai le service que vous n'êtes jamais
tu me fais de la pub pour acheter un
truc que j'ai déjà parce que gégé amazon
prime peut-être qu'il espère que tu
oublié qu'il avait je me réabonné ou
alors qu'ils m'empêchent de me
désabonner
et du coup je suis heureux de l'avoir
exactement je sais pas comment ça se
passe d'ailleurs se désabonner de
d'amazon prime il va repartir aux
remarques il mais il me serre mais je
sais pas je pense que doivent un petit
bouton se désabonner quoi ça peut je
pense j'espère en général c'est comme ça
quoi ouais je crois que c'est
obligatoire
d'ailleurs donc pourquoi ce que pour
netflix il y aussi pour hausser être je
crois que c'est ce petit bouton des
abonnements c'est une obligation fab
enfin peut-être il demande oui ce que
vous êtes sur wii fit sur halo pas de
chance quoi mais ce que tu es vraiment
sûrs d'avoir été sur quoi tu vois c'est
pas demain à paris p on te qui sur wii
est-ce que c'est ton dernier mot jean
pierre coiffe un fou oui c'est mon
dernier mot bon ok page de pub quand
même je lui sera fait une pub pour le
truc tout ça va tu peux faire dans ce
conte amazing serait pas si oui je crois
que c'est je crois que c'est obligé de
ce que ce soit facile maintenant à
l'époque ce n'était pas obligé
maintenant je crois que c'est obligé
c'est comme les ouvertures des bouquets
de fromage blanc sont faciles à ses fins
les fab
bah ça va pas tarder dans deux minutes
ouais et encore des services qui
t'oblige à envoyer une lettre
recommandée pour tous ses abonnés non
non ça va pas être obligatoire ah ouais
mais c'est eux c'est des trucs où tu ta
bonne en ont en physique genre d'art
team avait eu avec un truc comme ça où
tu étais obligé d'envoyer une lettre de
désabonnement mais c'est parce que tu
t'es c'est parce que tu ta abonnés en
physique si tu ta bonne par internet
normalement pas le truc ça vote par
internet s'ils n'ont plus le droit
maintenant mai
maintenant il ya longtemps au canal
aussi c'est assez chiant à pareille
époque donc peu lié je partais à
montpellier et en fait je te garder
l'abonnement même quand j'habitais plus
alors ils peuvent te faire suivre ta
connection notre nouveau domicile mais
bon moi je t'aime pas en mode comme ça
arrive des fois où j'ai eu mes tournois
en fait j'ai pas besoin d'un décodeur
canal plus avec moi quoi mais j'ai dû
payer jusqu'à la fin de l'année civile
ait eu 10 le monde tu ta bonne par
internet mais il te faut envoyer une
lettre pour t'aider abonnés a ouai bah
je sais pas si avec les nouvelles lois
là ça va ça encore lundi lorsque avec le
monde non mais je ne sais pas à quel
point mais normalement maintenant il
faut il faut le il faut un truc pour
cocher
d'après le monde c'est un journal papier
ce qu'ils réussissent à sais pas c'est
quoi les 46 et partage ses 25 + 10 et sa
femme exact de partir de 5 + 10 après on
verra la suite si la suite mais on va
pas on va pas on va pas passer dix
heures surtout pas la fin non mais bon
on se bat pas on s'en débarrasse en
niant deux heures non enfin ça va on bat
pas les isole alors attends ça
commençait avant ça marche pas alors là
heureusement quand elle petit échiquier
donc c'est de nouveau une berlinoise à
six a tancé ces partis c'est parti on
souffle on souffle bon c'est de nouveau
la même position qui hier c'est bien
parce qu'on a le petit chien en bas à
droite on va on va laisser les coûts
arrivée fab aussi sur le live et on a la
même position qu'hier après h3 donc on
va voir
sitôt pas la fatigue on attendait un
tempo serais-je à qui on fait juste la
même partie mais du coup on se fait
engueuler quoi par le pôle tiges qui en
bas à droite bon moi je regarde plutôt
le petit en bas à droite et là il a fait
fausse est là je peux le maître
américain
weaver seth et la procédure assez vite
la partie arrière des jeux peu de chance
kof
bon bah oui les premiers s'il
d'alzheimer sont déjà contraints
d'arrivée côté à te pas là ok vous
ferait tellement beau il conduit lui
serre la main pour pour lui dire tu dis
pas bonnes gens si yo ké boomers dégage
souffre à hk idée de venir battre moi
c'est la la la la petite manoeuvre
d'ailleurs attends je vais checker
immédiatement est-ce que ce qu'elle est
partie ce que cédric tout ça donc
h3 fou 17 tours des fouos 7g cap des
gages qui hk trouve ou alors il est
parti diriger la grave avec les noirs
d'être un mec qui viennent se qualifier
aux candidats mais en athlète
un autre lot un vrai aujourd'hui l'huile
est bien drivé bien comme il faut
ouais non il est drivé enfin certains
sasha grey tchouk ball exactement il est
parti ils sont fous au soft est parti
avec son fonds à cet effet ou g5 ça
ajoute m pouvant pour le moment dominé
férois 6,8 en fait tu m'en fous j'ai 5
alain fouché 5 un peu rare pour des
trois mais en fait il fait déjà une
partie entre nouvelle et opal of en 2016
à stavanger et le tour des 3 max est
donc là il a fait tous les cinq
donc il innove mais ses parents une
nouveauté après la très mauvaise
nouvelle
cacchione juste parce qu'il ya déjà le
sac et blanc staff qui jouait avec les
blancs non je pensais je pense qu'on est
trop dur directement la fab mais là
c'est quoi le pousser sur huit faisait 5
du coût de ce oui tu veux dire que le
câble que le cabinet peut pas venir
angers 5 le fourbe ce truc quoi ouais
ennuis le roi de la nouvelle n'est pas
en courant d'air rêve à 6 les pions
poussé dehors
il n'ya plus les dames ne te laisse pas
assez ce job n'a rien d'acquis l'europe
après voilà quelqu'un chez eux demo de
sprite fanta h5 a mais tu peux le
prendre mais si darrois g2 g3 ou 20 bon
après ce cas de chance si celui-ci sur
h5 qui fait pions prendre lorsqu'elle
web il veut un résumé dire bah écoute on
l'a fait sur sur youtube en fait donc tu
peux y aller bouillargues nuls en fait
d'où la c1 mais super vite fait après si
tu veux le résumé avec les coups bas tu
pourras des justes la vidéo ouais ça
peut paraître le le bon moyen d'avoir le
résumé c'est un petit quart d'heure et
donc il réfléchit topalov écoute c'est
une bonne nouvelle
c'est évidemment maxime qui le surprend
en premier ouais ouais ouais ouais ben
apparemment qu'est ce que je veux dire
j'aurais de ce que dit il il a tu la
mets du lilas fond mais a poussé 5 h 5
sa part être un plan quand même
l'impression que c'est clairement de
chroniques et qui est d'y jouer sans
pression du temps en pratique tout le
monde fait pousser 5,3 des trois joueurs
mais c'est adams quesada perez donc les
joueurs cubain est un mec qui s'appelle
baisse mais partent au gravier pareil
cas là c'est un autre basse et bien eu
deux
c'est pas parce qu'il n'a pas le niveau
de notre boss internationale donc on a
on s'attend à pousser 5
voilà qui est joué et tour des trois
jouets tempo donc maxime qui est
toujours dans la prépa ou trois ils sont
20 de suivre une partie l'écho adams
dans twin 2014 l'écho adam storting 2014
d'accord je pense qu'il faut aussi ce v6
faut aussi c'est ce que adams avait joué
mais qui est assez logique puisqu'en
fait bac et studiocanal bataille de
chars v6 3 b sat problème c'est que ton
roi il est il est scotché la défense du
fou et passants l'aident à l'eiblen il
demeure très bête c'est tour à des
attaques le food et ça tu t'en vas t
notes je montre un genre je peux kelkoo
matt m'a de l'opéra j'ai envie de te
dire voilà bon donc
donc faut éviter ça avec les noirs est
bon c'est pour ça que vous aussi ça a
l'air bien bien logique du coup tours a
les seins et b6 écrivait sur tour des
8,3 g73 baissé à l'exacte dallas bon ça
peut consoler avec le nord en général
les blancs ils essayent de revenir ou
trois que le foot
non mais avant de ré faut ici c'est faux
3 voilà où tour à des imbéciles mais
[ __ ] un jour mais wade il faut trois
directs voilà ici les gens bougent tout
reprend est décédé je sais de finale bon
mais genre h57 hôtel mêlée pour les
noirs ouais c'est quand même un petit
plus pour les blancs mais ces micro
microscopique après compte topalov
topalov il aime peut-être pas trop ce
genre de positions non mais bon il va
jouer des ajouts et des marines dans sa
vie bon c'est pas assez pas un début de
partie impressionnant pour pour le
joueur français fab non le problème
c'est que c'est dur d'être
impressionnant sur la berlinoise
mais bon soit disant tu voiture pour les
noirs sont des coups de bluff
donc on verra c'est peut-être vrai après
un oui
donc tu vois peut-être qu'en fait ça à
l'air à peu près égal comme ça mais
qu'en fait en pratique ça de chiant à
jouer et que s'imposer en tout cas pour
l'instant pas exclu liés dans sa prépa
c'est clair il joue vite donc
et qu'est ce que te dis ton lille a du
coup lilas il est il est heureux ou à nu
pour les blancs quoi attends je peux
aller prendre le
en fait je peux l'avoir deux endroits
différents patrie la surpêche et ce doit
être une évaluation mine un peu un peu
violent non mais c'est pas tout ça mais
il commet une évaluation un peu comme
les logiciels qu'on connaît ouais en
fait on peut la voir avec les
pourcentages d'estimation de gains ce
qui est peut-être mieux
et du coup je chope et n'a rien fait b6
surtemps détroit après ça change pas
grand chose est sûre tour des arts il va
faire fou ici c'est une transposition
c'est l'heure du coup il est où il est
l'un je te dire le pourcentage
je viens de beau jeu comprend peut-être
l'idée fabre s'est du coup sûr fouet
trois fous prend de 3 tours 33 tu peux
peut-être tu peux faire roi bessette et
du coup sûr tour d un mois m 6 quand
même et peut-être c'est un ordre de
cookies qui donne un poil plus de femmes
en remarque ça m'ennuie c'est pareil oui
ok apparemment il faut aussi se les
jarres préférence n'importe abc ce jouet
est ok le lilas il donne 60 2 % de
chance il faut autres mais qui préfère
largement reste le retour à dernier mais
53% je voulais gardiez je voulais gagner
la partie il y la vad il est là il y
aura un truc de rap non feinte
bah ouais ça peu non lily là j'ai pas
fait pour un truc comme ça je gagnerai
en blitz wah wah wah qu attends j'ai
peut-être un petit coup d'oeil aux deux
autres l'a vu que ça tu vois pour juste
ma mailhac aux imams et yacco j'ai envie
de te dire c'est chaud du cal but c'est
la plante juste un passage comme savons
il se passe des trucs en france et pas
que
on ne s'est pas moquée pour copains est
née ponant sa sandrine
non donc une épaule ou un écossais choix
aussi
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel je
reviens juste la partie parce que c'est
un peu non 3-5 jamais des cadres comme
variante pour re pour tout le monde en
fait ça ressemble un peu à l'idée de la
partie de mvf contredit glas la boudeuse
unique entre les mairies pas été pas mal
hein ça crisse b5 pour pour pousser pour
douze autres sont donc il est très actif
niva fou mais ils ont bien très
intéressante galfond dans ce tournoi
mais bon après je sais pas si mon rapide
combiné podor position 7o max km les
[ __ ] en tout cas faut prendre trois
tours prendre trois ça va être joué un
fab je suis déçu mais on est donc là est
ce que tu peux et non tu fais tour des
huit valeurs kg 5 c'est idiot tête il
veut commencer par h5
et ouais mais h5 ce que kg 5 c'est pas
un coup
jarre ok on va faire hg j'imagine qu'ils
éprouvent cette tour et peut-être autour
eux qui ont tout dans ce site
mais non ça a l'air pas mal ça attention
pas que ça encore joué dans sa page mais
je vais fermer les deux autres partis
pour compte
pourquoi on souffre pas de ludique de
larges que décrit dans le chat elle va
sûrement gagné les départage mais j'ai
peur que mam et néo pop associe bah
écoute c'est wallace est probable un
bien d'autres pinces et puis peu importe
son nom peut que s'occuper de son propre
jeu oui mais on peut quand même espérer
que les autres perdent aussi corps
passage oui oui mais pour le coup on
pourra n'y faire pour le coup non ça ça
c'est difficile mais c'est vrai qu'au
tour prochain de toute façon il faut
voir qui aura le match est née postaux
et je sais même pas si on n'espère pas
ma femme j'ai peur d'une victoire de
sauts sans fin avec le point de bonus ce
qu'en fait si commença à beaucoup de
points de bonus il me fait vraiment très
peur c'est moi qui ai concevoir avec
l'école il ya deux jours je savais même
pas qu'il existait ça tu trembles
non mais en fait une remarque ce nom
mais si maxime va en demi ça va mais je
veux dire par là que j'ai plus peur de
se gagner le tournoi que enfin vous
verrez les points
connais pas bah tu commences à me faire
peur avec saurait vous dites galfond
n'était sauteur à la perche quand il
avait 17 ans et donc un athlète je
savais pas sa joie je voudrais voir le
dauphin qui la phase 6 mais on va voir
c'est une aubaine c'est intéressant bon
je pense max surnom de son cavalier bon
c'est f4 f5 extension à commenter les
championnats de monde de rapides et
bliss bah oui bien sûr non mais tu ta ta
vraiment où enfin là c est fou stop à
taza toutou qui est commenté en fait
t'as tout qui est commentée donc h6
jouer donc fabu fait quoi on fait
tourner un tour des trois breaks ou deux
tours 2
sa part de manger du pain après je ne
sais pas s'il faut aller sur youtube
avec ses cinq peut-être est fou c'est 6
du coup ça et qui crée le lit peu compte
fait flouer 6 3 b ça tu étais toujours
mieux
mais oui tu peux jouer que ces 5 mai est
fausse et 6 mais je sais pas ce fou
peut-être un peu stoppé aussi sur
l'instant peut-être ces 5 es fou ou six
comme ça tu a bloqué le cavalier avec
les noirs c'est peut-être son idée enfin
tu empêches caïds et 4 kg 5 et humer lui
font en russie ce prêt tu me le faut
aussi ce même dire avec toi sur cahier
des quatre classes échanger des fois
faire gaffe à vos wii non mais en fait
non c'est ça il va faire tourner un ses
cinq tours tu es sûr tour des trois fois
6-1 et sur cavaliers bouger 5
peut-être tu vois il te bloque attendait
un ses cinq frères logique après je
pense avec les blancs se retourner à ses
5 tu peux aussi te bouger le cavalier
plutôt que faire pour des trois genres
qu'allié je n'ai pas agi quatre pour
faire f4 et vous cueillez cinq défensif
est g5 fait cavaler f5
bon je pense il faut ici c'est ce qu'ont
réussi vraiment à pas ce qu'est ce qui
peut juste rester assis nous essayerons
après des fonds peut dégager le fugu kg
s'est toujours pas mais peut-être ils se
laissent prendre
ouais mais si on est droit tu apprendras
du tour 17 enfin je sais pas je vais
essayer jamais mais c'est toujours un
poil plus sympa
ben t'as pas de risque laquelle
non non non je et donc voilà on pensait
à peut-être c'est simple on espère qu'il
va pas le faire du coup c'est logique
non mais peut faire aussi fou aussi ce
qui est des quatre tours des huit
peut-être non tour ouais détroit ce que
tu voulais faire on est d'accord lui
genre c5 vous faut si ce beauf détroit
vous des trois bouffées 6 mais bon la
tour eiffe trop les comptines le premier
entre oui en fait cette position est que
laure on saute ça doit aller pour le
nord il a fait ces cinq on est portion à
bernois soient bons efforts sur la bns à
la la je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce
qu'il faut faire face on s'est
transformée on est en mode super saiyan
c'est à dire qu'à ce niveau la fac je
sais pas ce que tu a bouffé à midi tabou
fait quoi midi
alors je me suis mangé de l'avocat de
l'avocat est ce que je pensais que tu
avait mangé de la saucisse de francfort
tu vois un avocat s est ensuite je me
suis échauffé je suis fait j'ai coupé
des poireaux que j'ai fait avec des
lentilles corail curie crème de coco
ah ouais non non non cet été a été sur
dur du très haut niveau ça ta tête sur
moi je suis allé tu as vu la journée je
suis allé au fast-food asiatiques ah bah
oui mais voilà c'est bien plus sain que
ce que j'ai mangé moins bon c'est vrai
je me suis je fais on lit qu'il a joué
cavalier h4 aulas la fab on est partout
à l'eau comme des mauvais allons pas le
cavaliere
non mais franchement la fab c'est un
niveau de qualité et tu as demandé ce
qui peut faire g6 avec les défunts f4 g5
ouais mais c'est trop fins quoi est ce
qui fait donc si c'est fou aussi sont
fait quoi il faut ici l4g 5
ouais mais c'est pas ce qu'on peut faire
f5 pouf pouf tour f3 et on rentre dans
des salons ou presque on est vraiment
mieux mais après le problème parce que
je me suis rendu compte que sur f5
peut-être que tu fous 3-2 quoi ouais ah
ça c'est pénible ce qu'après la majorité
elle peut jouer aussi de l'autre côté et
surtout tu peux et même éventuellement
garder parfois ton points à 2 et le
soutenir avec la la tour ça peut arriver
des fois un petit soit pas enfermé passe
très souvent c'est très dangereux
d'aller prendre un plan comme ça parce
qu'il ya des trois ne voit plus le jour
et ils sont fermés mais bon si on va
faire ça avec les noirs comme kevin le
monde
balfour au sort et puis après jamais
trop avec de clouage en fait donc
ouais donc c'est quoi la position si
c'est ce que tu souffres quatre nommés
de faire presque 4 g 5 kg d'os que si
impossible ce qui menaçait et de te
taper de fou et ward et c'est vrai mais
donc ça recommence bon on va voir est-ce
que ça recommence vraiment c'est tout ce
que je peux tenter tout raté trois fois
6 vous fait aussi ce repartir avec la
tour et mentor un pion de moins soit ça
soit bon quand même faut b3 donc je fais
à 5 et 2 on a fait réfléchir mais 32.3
et est-ce que tu attendes sur ces 4
juste sur b3 b6 à f 4g 5 ça bouffe
bouffe en 2003 et donc je crois qu'il
est vraiment ferme en ferme et là ok
donc bonne nouvelle gp12 et la
serrurerie
mais je crois comprendre le fou pour
reprendre f1 je pense et toros est aussi
son concept pénible balaté pénible c'est
pas fini encore mme été pénible voilà ça
va ok
et ça serait clos donnait sans plus non
encore bas il joue très vite bon après
il vous vite souvent mais c'est très
probable qu'ils connaissent en tout cas
il a récité l'ouverture bon là c'est
juste le déroulement logique est ce que
h55 ou ici bas ont fait gagner cinq noms
well idc avec les noirs de fer ag as.g
et j'ai six peut-être alors ce truc avec
here you have any petites soeurs tués
jeudi à detroit ok et si du coup il fait
fou prend prise du port la même solution
h un nom de cet échec jusqu'à égaliser
des intérêts ok c'est sympa tout ça
ouais on peut être le mieux pour le nord
c'est ce qu'on regarde au début j'ai 5
km 5 fois ci pour faire gober cette se
barrer mais un peuple kg soit tu fais
pas les nerfs tranquille du coup de tête
retour des 8 mai réunit délicieuse en
fait on va jouer de prendre prendre tour
f3 recettes tf6 notre force un peu trash
et j'ai l'impression que je prends aussi
cela les toits non crsa du majin tour
accises toi je suis tu je pensais que je
pense pas que tu t'es trop le temps de
tactique mais bon est-ce que ça je gagne
mais bon déjà c'est une bonne tête je te
faire f 4 bouffe et de conclure en bas
et toutes les finales de pions sont
gagnants parce que je fais pas de plan
passés avec mon cas 33eme j'aurais fait
roi g20 le taux facial ou réformé peu
importe
j'étais encore murray wen oms a une
bonne tête ça des bonnes têtes de
partout écoute c'est plutôt bien pour
l'instant balordi dit quoi par diddy g5
cavale
cinq fois aux 6 kg cet arrêté huit lui
doit prendre et huit cavaliers u6 à feu
6-3 7-6 8/6 tour des deux mois j'ai vu
ça aussi mais c'est pas hyper envie mais
peut-être que trois ans le seul espoir
l'autre était pourrie mais de son
élimination est peut être ce sauveur je
ne sais pas mais bon est beaucoup moins
fort que vous en faites pas on est tous
vus sans lui on avait compris que tu es
blanc était mieux on va fin dégage enfin
toi t'es nul moi je m'appelle fabi
bicois dégage maintenant l'agresseur il
aimait me permets de l'or que nous ils
donnent plus +0 30 au début puis après
tu donnes + 1 40 comme un ballon mais
gère pas de chance ce sera quoi te sers
stockfisch en fait s'il est moins fort
que toi il à tv5 il te sers pour voir
dans des peaux de banane on gagne c'est
tout mais en fait sinon il ne comprend
rien voilà on l'a on vient de prouver le
no fake et la voilà on la voit en gros
c'est lui qui tombe pas sur un gros
moteur
moi non plus je tourne pas sur un gros
moteur pardon c'est peut-être les
avocats s qui est bouclée avocat s est
couplé au fast-food asiatique fait assez
la ccam un cocktail très puissant ouais
donc cavalière et ça a l'air assez fort
c'est en plus un grief ça arrive jouer
outre george final possible peut-être
mais qui bien aussi pour les blancs
c'est faux aussi dans le même genre de
truc un peu aux 6 kg 7 est en fait tu
feras beissat en parler c'est bien vous
font rentrer mais a fait peut-être fou
rentrée un truc concret comme ça tendez
vite
autour des 3 j'imagine on échange en
france et six taureaux cette
organisation mais bon roi des singes
qu'on s'active chopin pour prendre ses
sept jeux pas ce qui se passe tu fais à
5 tu prends le 5 je sais pas je suis pas
un peu trop actif 15 octobre mais bon et
on a juste envie que je sache les blancs
sont pas disons alors robin 15 euros non
avec le truc de marine ouais mais bon
oui mais ça c'est pas parce que tu as
raison tu dois pas gagné ouais juste ses
joueurs ce que sait pas encore mais là
et demi quand même parce que la tour
elle est vraiment forte et le roi blanc
il va s'activer on voit pas trop comment
les noirs et dans ses pas et s'est
invité dans monte dans la zone entre
gagnants nuls coiffe introduit les
gagnants ils en ont fait juste un petit
tour sur les hôtels chics est bon mais
chaud très chaud pour moi il se passe ce
jour et galfond de bordeaux moment celui
qui sort le mieux de l'ouverture c'est
max il a pris un f5 et gf
ok on n'avait pas trop regarder ça parce
qu'on était content de bain à jack dion
post.fr tour des huit c'est sûr nous
faire gagner cette finale mais bon ok il
aime juste 1000 m bref je sais pas c'est
gagnant malawi c'est peut-être pas con
ce qu'il a fait aux play-offs mais à
leur tour des 3 je pense le programme
très bon sens fait débloquer était pièce
de viande halal d'un petit quelque chose
comme ça pour d4
mais là du coup on fait contre le roi
virage 5 où je pense à ces gagnants
grosse prépare aujourd'hui comme on dit
parfois que maxime est un peu de mal
avec les blancs qui est peut-être c'est
juste douteux b6 16e coup on avait dit
fos istres
il faut aussi les le coup que la dame ce
prochain jeu en fait c'est peut-être
déjà trop grave
l'autre en vote enfin la joie des
détails comme ça je fais des bêtises qui
a pas l'air débile mais ben tu te
penches est libre m y'a jamais pur
transposer dans les trucs qu'on avait vu
qu'elle allait faire un b sat
il nous laisse rentrer un 17-2 là son
envie d'ouvrir mon goût mais enfin tu
bouges pas le nom mais ok bon je vois
pas maxime l'a ratée mais bon au près de
deux ans de contrat ni en fait ni keyyo
conquis les mallettes les normes et qui
est bon enfin ton plus remonté le roi h5
quand même quelque chose
bon on va voir ce qu'il faut là dessus
mais les libyens max stylisant le chat
invite au dur à défendre avec moins de
dix minutes je pense est dur à défendre
tout court un cruiser en tout cas c'est
plutôt plutôt bien parti pour l'instant
c'est quoi une prairie bat fabrice
répondre bon en fait c'est juste du
travail effectué en amont à la maison
sois toi-même soit partait préparateur
ou en collaboration ou tu anticipes un
peu ce qui peut se passer et et analyse
les variantes à fond et donc là en fait
maxime a pas vraiment joué un coup par
lui-même pour l'instant il ajuste
réciter des trucs qu'ils connaissaient
ils obtenu une position pas loin d'être
gagnante
donc pour ça qu'on dit bonne probable ce
qu'il a très bien préparé la partie il a
bien travaillé en amont et
et voilà il a complètement dominé son
adversaire dans l'ouverture peu comme si
au foot tu travailles les combinaisons
sur les coups de pied arrêtés et et que
tout ce que tu as travaillé la semaine à
l'entraînement tu arrives à faire le
truc en match dont tu es content de mon
travail en amont donc bonne prépa voilà
ouais bien joué et bon maintenant il va
falloir conclure sa loi français qui
semblent fab énorme favori
bah ouais c'est bon alors il est au
mieux placé et lampion passé qui va vite
et aussi quand il a envie en fait donc
c'est la grande différence dans les deux
structures sec et non un quatre contre
trois à l'ale dame mais qui sert à rien
bastien tu feras jamais dit on bosse
avec ça et les blancs par contre oui le
quatre contrats de l'autre côté ils
peuvent le valoriser
donc première truc deuxième chose c'est
que le roi noir est cantonné astel dame
tu resteras russe est encore ils
empêchent des tours de rentrée il bloque
un peu les pions passé ce sera une toute
autre histoire mais avec le roi l'a
battue et du reste du jeu c'est comme un
problème
laurent blanc peut remonter vers le
centre pas les virages 5 donc pas mal de
choses qui font que clairement les
blancs sont mieux c'est un avantage
quasi décisif mais jamais si simple non
ben c'est bon tu peux laisser échapper
un truc des ventes miraculeuse parfois
mais c'est un bon gros avantage
comme quoi être bien préparé ça c'est un
projet de jeu par ex donc il va y
prépare l'arrivée du roi vert h5 tout
bêtement waouh enfin il ya des options
en tout cas c'est un coup utile dans
tout l'éclat donc souviens j'avais
vraiment pas comment topalov tu peux
même faire quoi que ce soit il vient
juste de regarder lille accès ce qui met
sur roger deux noms sont âge 91
ouais après l'hymne pas en finale le
stockfisch aussi fort mais oui ça
devrait bien être ça c'est énorme
un 90c car maintenant c'est plus que ce
que j'imaginais que jour à 10 75 m
ses écrasantes chez écrasant donc il a
fait tour des huit tours des huit tours
des huit comtés loin non froide from a
de toute façon tu risques que jamais
autour des deux parce que dès que la
tour par an ces deux il ya aussi ce 7,8
battu veulent m'envoyer puis en direct
en fait et tu montres leroy
vraiment je pense que ça va je pense à
gagner très vite femmes bobos écoute
victoire une victoire assez facile qui
ce qui se profile fait dire juste 90% de
chance le descente que je vous l'annoncé
il reste encore la deuxième partie avec
les noirs non je sais je ride un jeu du
genre ce sera pas fini fini quoi il fait
quoi là topalov tu penses bosch
ben je rêverais quasi envie d'abandonner
avec les noirs en fait ouais mais bon il
peut pas faire ça non mais t'as pas de
coûts passent et je pense suffisant aux
parents mais c'est très dur de suggérer
un bon goût une position mauvaise on a
donc il y aura fait une faute quoi b6
ben jack moderne et c'est fini
maxime qui aura été très propre dans la
finition qui est atteinte et regardez le
coût déjà londres aurait été fou 17
quand même parce que je sais pas ce
qu'on disait en début ce truc en fait
pour répéter faut vraiment être hyper
près ce que maxime flex à nador
en fait tout ça d'une fade il n'a pas
peur d'aller au combat les savates s'il
y perd près mais quand tu es un peu
comme topaloff
enfin l'arrière machin c'est un grand
maître d'un niveau moindre je sais pas
genre tu es 26,50 ou je sais pas quoi on
était moins bien préparés c'est hyper
dur de toujours
répéter en plus quand des mecs comme ça
en face à rennes en clair moreau ans le
dribble quoi bon tu essaies de jouer un
truc où tu espères que l'autre a pas
trop révisé et que je tourne et arrive
pas ça où tu te fais taper dessus sans
rien pouvoir faire
ouais c'est un choix un peu bizarre
après topalov c'est pas c'est pas le
perdreau de l'année 1
il est au courant mais bon il s'est
trompé sur un coup en fait c'est trop tu
ne connaissait pas jusque là je suis nul
l'armée ou les fonds encore film non
mais je veux dire c'est un essai
exemplaire quoique saverina c'est un
truc très solide et là en fait on en
quelques coups quoi ça prend
complètement l'eau mais fait d'éclat
pousser cette majorité
ça peut être un problème pour les noirs
non mais du coup je me rappelle quand on
a cas quand il est à l'époque où il
était bien préparée quand tu les
berlinois de même mon speech s est tous
contre max il te reste l étrange coup de
théorie quasi tempo quoi au 35e coup ils
se défendent bizarre les prendre des
pions à 2 justement et le foot et on
ferme et enfin tout ça il connaissait
tous par coeur
ouais j'en fais tu peux pas prendre
devant l'échiquier si tu apprends tu as
besoin de jeu pointant de calcul face
est horrible mais juste tu sais que ça
marche ça marche on vas tu peux rentrer
dedans il a fait ces quatre topper bon
j'ai quand même parce que je trouve que
tu as peut-être faire juste b5 non on
s'en aller avec laurent
ouais enfin de soissons c'est un truc
comme ça qui va raju a pas trop ce que
tu peux faire en fait avec les doigts
rajhi juste perception quoi je tour
achevé de 6e le pion à dégager à
mélanger six f-16 dame ouest il faut
montrer c'est que tous ces scénarios là
en fait même scénario là c'est
complètement fini parce qu'on va jamais
chrétiens ont passé alors ya une méthode
pour bloquer d'éventuels fonds à 5
non me veux tu fais c'est 3 à 3 et 4 à 3
c'est fini ça passera jamais se toucher
à rien et que les blancs tu peux les ne
peut faire mieux passer par faut juste
bien savoir tout faire ce petit trident
et c'est fini mais si tu fais un écrit
jean roy prend g5 b4y tu regardes pas
voilà bon bah là une inscription en
personne
pas de chance mais bon il suffit de
prendre ses précautions en amont et
charles pasqua
c'est fini il y aura rien rien et quand
les noirs font des quatre jeux sont tous
pareils monsieur on commencera à prendre
je suis fait le tri dans quoi tu fais le
tri dans c'est un peu comme comme
aquaman quoi s'est construit dans et en
refaire un tour chez les autres n'est
peau n'est menée pour un il a toujours
eu mais tu vois j'ai enfin vous pariez à
la valoriser enfin c'est pas qu'on dise
non donc ça ça margot super emma mais
qui est quand même l'adversaire numéro 1
d'après leurs villes et gagnent enfin
gagnant il est mieux aussi
ouais donc peut-être que en fait tout le
monde va tout le monde va passer quoi
observer 10 mots ce qu'il promet cinq
non masqué prend des cinq épreuves et
cinq français quatre dont il faut déjà
faire un truc qu'on trop ça mais du coup
ça lui permettre de faire tourner un
peut-être ou high concept un peu la
pression
ça commence à ressembler un truc comme
amis aussi mais pas cette année c'est
qu'ils semblaient devant mais ses choix
bon on retournerait chez maxim alors
c'est chez maxim
il est will donc ces quatre ok je
connaissais pas je ressens que j'aime
bien y 50 points elo grève sans point
même un bon d'être avec nous bien il
vaut le président mais aussi poséidon
mais bon aquaman il un trident aussi j'y
parle pas c'est pas moi qui lui donnais
en fait je trouve qu'il l'a quoi il y
avait son petit sceptre à troyes dans
l'aube mais oui poséidon aussi animer
des petites pépites calotte pédagogique
alors maxime rey donc il ya l'embarras
du choix mais je pense que là il peut
pas vraiment même se tromper non non une
opa se trouvait pas ça va bien se passer
bien se passer à la mon avis et c'est
fini c'est fini après topalov topalov
qui est plus dans le coup topalov c'est
peut-être la dernière fois qu'on le
verra dans ce genre de
deux tournois non je le vois pas refaire
des grand prix dans deux ans
difficilement mais vont aussi fière de
son lots et qu'on l'a vite peut être
qu'il aura envie de jouer un point
tour 4 en fait c'est logique tour aux
caps est pas de faire un g4 ce que tu
vois j'ai quatre direct des quatre
échecs et tout ça m'a tellement pas te
faire rater un tubercule est aussi mais
bon donc voilà tour 4 au moins tu
t'attaques le pion tu te fais un peu
sage pour ton roi et puis toi bien quoi
le petit veau riz comme dans un data
tous de tout tout tout petit effet le
petit passage par aldata cette petite
musique je fasse état déjà
non je leur dis qu'ils proposeront à ses
8 oui bonsoir bonne pas trop peur non en
c4 tordre et 5 pour essayer de ramener
le roi non mais c'est logique versée
c'est assez exemplaire comme coup en
partie dure à jouer peut-être assez vite
par contre bon mais tout est dur enfin
quoi faire mais bon c'est un pédagogique
non comme coup pour revenir là bas c'est
oui oui c'est mieux de faire sa queue
que l'on nous montre comment traire la
finale droit permettant il a fait naître
des 5 by d'hypoxie dit pourquoi elle
trop de g3 que le roi
un bon je pense ça change pas grand
chose mais en fait pas ce que fait leur
marque à tous c'est la seule pièce qui
va aussi tout droit qu'en diagonale quoi
et c'est juste un peu contre intuitif
par rapport à la vie de tous les jours
parce que pour toi c'est important pour
moi pour tout le monde le cheval de
course et la ligne droite le roi non
riches c'est pareil si tu es en h1 et
souvenirs à schwyz imagine un échec
évident tu mets sept coups vous faites
un endroit bon si tu fait des
va-et-vient tu fais cette possible alors
dit s'affole à il passe à +4 c'est la
vente qu'on avait vu 3,5 pour apprendre
à 6 face à peu rentrer là dedans en fait
ambroise et 6 3 5 tours à schwyz si ça
peut vraiment rentrer là-dedans
bouffarde mais là c'est très bien ça
c'est le plus simple parfois c'est de
les changer les pièces pour convertir
son avantage
c'est le cas donc c'est probablement le
scénario qu'on va qu'on va voir dans
cette danse est partie fab avec un
maxime qui est vraiment facile aurait
laférois c8 donc bon soit pas changé
grand chose
je pense qu'on peut le faire aussi sous
le rush 5
mais bon aussi ce salaire bien parce que
comme ça on empêche les tours d2
désactivé compagnie est l'objet d'assez
sur la huitième et rachida je pense que
du coup on fait je suis forcé un peu ce
genre de choses enfin tu vas faire
jusqu'à 7 ou 8 en fait non c'est grâce à
sa voiture en ville
4 pourquoi alors dit que c'est pas gagné
sauf qu'on attend de moi et des pensions
bon cela dit on a pas mal de yens 3 où
ces trois ans je leur dis juste
3 non et si nous fermons bref si ce sera
un prédicateur soit gagnée en fait après
de ce qui va arriver que ça va très vite
vers b2 ouvert ces trois points en jeu 5
j'aurais été capable de me faire piéger
comme ans qu'on l'achète quand je sors
mes contrats d'ordi j'aurais été capable
de faire ça donc il faut juste attendre
un courant juillet le pion et d'avoir
bouffage six bras d'un autre côté après
tours 8
après ouais en fait tu fais rush 5 eric
tu t'en vas pas faire recette
non mais bon c'est juste pour monter
enfin un piège incroyable psychédélique
mais bon tu fais juste 3,5 d'abord 3.63
pranger 5 c'est gagné mais bon il ya
encore des pièges malgré tout toujours
faire attention
non mais là quand même avec les blancs
d'un peu d'eau et le le bâton pour se
faire battre
on trouve facile la griserie du succès
et voilà travnik en sueur le mur de
berlin est tombé issue je me dis un
garçon qui n'est plus ça
ok et machins et pau nippo un haut
niveau d'après leur dis c'est pas si à
la fin il peut se faire mater en fait
mais je pense que ça clairement pas être
l'adversaire du truc mais pour moi la
fois qu'il est beaucoup beaucoup de
réussite n'a pas l'air d'être en grande
forme
alors après
ok vin par le bruit sur damas
si j'ai quatre mois plus ou moins
compliqué oui mais bon j'aime pas voir
un robot blanc à l'e3 comme ça on verra
partie de maxime et les tours à huit
bombes ont ponctué le roi faire recette
est transposée dans un final quoi
parfois on est là pour nous là on leur
tu es allé mével faut concrétiser dans
le bon là bas je te mets sont bourse en
voilà je me risque
je me laisse quand même je lâche une
info pour une fois ça pour te dire à
quel point que l'info est lâché si je
voulais c'est deux places de plus 8 à 0
c'est ouf comme ça nous on gagne on est
à + 5
les tests dans une autre position on va
pas tu as besoin de faire ça tout de
suite très digne karaté pire contre
élevé à la dernière compét tout est
possible non faustino était beaucoup
plus difficile celle du holding phare
faux parce qu'en fait tu as les dames
or tous hyper chiant à calculer ouais en
fait c'est plus simple parfois des
positions aucun petit avantage mais que
tu ta rennes a calculé tu as juste y
aller mécaniquement et tu connais un peu
le truc que un truc cool ordi peut-être
plus disent pas ce que fait ta une ligne
qui gagne hyper compliqué ok tu as raté
bien plus 10 m'ont fait juste et dur
alors que des fois même un gain de +0 5
peut être pas à ce point mais plus un
c'est peut-être en fait juste très
simple et la france
je pense que quasiment tout le chat
gagnant à quoi sa position ouais je
pense aussi je pense ça c'est vraiment
assez simple à gagner alors séparé ce la
lettre c h à 12h ou asha 200 oui mais
c'est la presse ouais c'est la nasse et
ça c'est chevaux c'est une sorte
d'avocat j'imagine je suis pas seul à la
plupart des avocats qu'on achète ses des
avocats est d'ailleurs alors on dit
qu'il ya eu abandon c'est possible qu'il
y ait un abandon la der ouais il ya eu
abandon après white ou 5 3 des 8 7
oui je crois j'ai six et ils à tours en
fait les amis bon ben voila et gagner
bon ça c'est une bonne chose de faite tu
reçois est une petite pub ouais et après
on file vers l'est vers les deux autres
parties importantes du jour pour nous
allez allez petite pub victoire
tranquille
ouais on a pas on n'a pas tremblé et on
va aller
du coup bas peut-être vers l'epo bernie
pauvre qu'est ce qui s'est passé dames
serge et 5 h 5 km 7 g 4 bref quatre
dames j'ai un bien sûr mais bon il va
peut-être 27 une sorte de blocus où il
va raccrocher mettre son rang h3
défendent g4 faire torah c'est un oui
bah s'approcha fond mais le truc c'est
google panda 2 minutes en photo
donc je prie vous cherchez un avocat ce
débat c'est juste un avocat normal mais
je le cherchais à erbin devrait donc
maxi lâcher la raf quel but
donc ouais torah c'est un rouage 3 il va
essayer de défendre et varois g3 essayer
de faire peut-être p3 tour à ses seins
et pousser les pions mais galfond
n'guema l'otan fable galfingue qui est
plus qu à deux minutes
ce peut être le problème je prouve que
nos facs
c'est un avocat très classique voilà
bonne densité et la voilà donc comme
c'est 3 je crois pour ces 4 alors je
leur dis sans ballon sais pas pourquoi
la tête il aurait dû passer plus vite et
que saddam je sais pas ou utilisent fait
absolument à l'anru six fois les 11 6 et
attaques des trois stylos des fonds avec
ta dam un hymne aux questions lors de la
vente aux poudres je pense comprendre
c'est que madame de six noms au roi
machin dame assise en fait pour défendre
des trois territoires d un super à 2 je
fais toujours ses quatre petits bouge
plus trop mais oui on remarque sur c4
s'est pas encore nulle direct mais si tu
veux défendre avec lada williams sisters
partage aussi ça qu il espérait de faire
un truc comme ça mais bon tous les cas
tu dois wayne rooney blessé mais le
problème est là du coup ils te dis que
ça ses pairs dont on peut là encore
foutu non plus les gestions incroyable
ordi donne plus trois pour les ballons
pourquoi ont ils fait 1,4 sur dame prend
je peux pour bien trier damas 3 pro v6
s'agissait d'un trophée
c'est lui qui vient de contre et c'est
lui qui te contre en fait mais c'est pas
flagrant enfin j'aurai plus grosse que
ce que alors il a fait b3 du queen avait
fait le truc logique torah et fit
nancéen motivation gagner grâce à la
pendule en fait mais je suis pas sur ce
style est la position sont mais si je
pensais vraiment fait si je commençais
vraiment à comprendre là le truc c'est
qu'avec les noirs n'arrive pas à créer
de menaces genre vraiment doigt parce
qu'elle étonnant c'est que ok tu crées
pas de menace mais normalement tu fais
pas défoncer avec juste un taux de moins
il n'est pas plus de -3 mais tu dois te
faire contre défoncé le roi ce que tu
arrives vraiment pas à toucher les
blancs bizarrement prince l'histoire des
courses et c'est torse six braquages six
barres mes écouteurs les joueurs qui
tiennent leur rang mais d'abord il est
plus 4c fantasy que la vraie de la vente
âges augmente augmente augmentons convoi
pourquoi ah si je comprends en fait
comme la dame s'est éloigné de des cases
blanches mains il va pouvoir faire
d'amis 6 et te mettre la tour en c6 et e
coupé enfin il veut partir du tour ans
et 7 une tour en c6 et il va te couper
toutes les cases pour attaquer g4
laiteux poste l'autre côté du coup c'est
fini mais c'est vrai que si tu mets une
tour ans est une tour en ici et la dame
en c1 il rentre et toi tu fais rien quoi
faire j'ai quatre allemands et sereine
mais c'est ouais
non mais pauvre tu sais pas quoi en
penser d'un côté je suis rassuré parce
que son niveau de jeu me paraît assez
famélique
voilà notre côté je me dis c'est comme
parfois faute à des équipes qui sont au
tennis ou au foot je me rappelle quand
je savais que j'étais fou avec la le
match wawrinka medvedev a lui à l'open
super arena et domine tout le premier
set il a les balles de set
bon bah il met une balle dehors sur sa
balle de 7 à 10 cm de la leaf armes
parce qu'ils sont de même cinq
centimètres de la ligne juste à côté
pour bas l'autre gagne le premier set
après justine le défonce quoi pas alors
que tout le premier set c'est wawrinka
qui domine enfin tu suis un papa il perd
le set puis après avoir fait huit tu as
perdu matches nuls qua non mais vous
êtes débloque aussi ça donne confiance
au sein meneboo je sais pas où ils ont
mis leur poussif mais prêts bon faut
quand même le battre de près par bon
après ce qui rassure c'est que il est à
quatre points de retard donc il faut il
faut vraiment qu'ils aillent minimum en
finale pour poser problème à maxime font
une qui gagne le tournoi lui aussi donc
il ya quand même de la marche quoi le
jeu pour gagner le tournoi il ya quand
même de la marge et s'assemblent
ouais bon voilà ça fait deux pions de
plus pour mam est donc en fait ils
gagnent tous mais en fait peut être que
j'irai au niveau est beaucoup plus
flagrant rapide à mais c'est moi c'est
mon livret échecs et les autres ça va
être la sio là là là tu as ta ta crème
l'élite de la nation vladimir kramnik
pour qu'ils aient moins nul lui dis
qu'il faut arrêter de rockets mais en
fait la messe est signé en russie
en fait le truc c'est que gris encore
fait nullement et e
qu'est ce que je vais en fait ça va pas
changer le point fondamental de ces
chocs calandres la non mais bon c'est ça
fait crème tournage suit pas et tu as
fait ta consommation d'électricité
pendant toute ta vie en deux heures pour
pour savoir ce que ça va être pas
rockeuse et chaque page mais c'est
intéressant comme le 966 intéressant
mais fait un peu avoir les 970 euros
audience ça fait chier tout le monde
allez on aime bien mais bon en fait
on est très peu à aimer quoi et non par
ok ça va rien arranger
enfin c'est pas exact va faire de
l'audience tu va rénover le truc comme
lui ils paient dans son monde et chaque
échec
il a fait que ça de toute sa vie
peut-être mais il était très fort c'est
pas le problème mais mai face c'est pas
une idée révolutionnaire qui va d'un
courant des échecs trois mois c'est moi
ce qui m'a peut continuer tous quoi moi
ce qui m'a le plus étonné dans cette
idée ce qu'ils pensent que c'est une
idée novatrice venir seul ou non mais ce
que je vois c'est qu'il fait échec toute
sa vie mais il s'est peut-être failli
sais pas qui revient une ancienne règle
en fait moi c'est ça qui m'a le plus
étonné parce qu'en fait c'est quelque
chose de novateur enfin palmarès les
mecs jouent comme ça au 16e siècle
donc en termes d'innovation si tu veux
c'est un peu spécial quoi c'est ça en
fait qui m'a un peu étonné parce que
c'est quand même un mec qui est cultivé
et qui enfin je sais pas ou alors il
connaît même pas l'histoire des échecs
mais ça m'étonnerait leur prendre des
ballons cousu main en faute
mais en fait ouais c'est une ancienne
règle du tu pousses un peu un peu
étonnante et n'est possible et aussi 1 0
est là ils ont tous gagné un dépôt est
carrément gagner autant mais bon la
position était complètement un oui moyen
tour ses huit au prochain tour c'est
vite et donc on s'intéresse un petit peu
à la partie va jusqu'à ceque andreikin
parce que c'est le prochain tour pour
maxime et là il masque m matin bon ben
je crois que aux fins d'une quoi il n'ya
pas les dames damage de sim et d'objets
quatre dom j'ai trois à cinq mois ce
matin tous les horaires d'un match
depuis un an on recommence donc ça à
faire nul bon normalement qui seront
primés tâche et capinghem les hasards de
nouvelles sont sourds dans la course va
way i son pays de quoi dégager que l'on
veut plus vous voir donc
donc on veut pas sacré la dame sur le
fou battu peu hein mais voit pas bien ce
coup ci après tu peux peut-être tiers et
annule encore mais le truc c'est que les
morts peuvent se faire par peur si l'on
peut à l'envi sur un bon budget est
peut-être la dermatite donc c'est juste
suicidaire mais là ils vont faire nul
c'est sûr et du coup l'autre partie
intéressante ce qu'aime aussi ou en
gallo navarra parce que c'est le
prochain tour de mam et donc pas on
espère qu'il va pas jouer à navarra
quand même c'est d'abord une finale à +5
hier intentions ouais bah c'est pour ça
qu'on espère une qualification de wang
hao quand même mais huang hao wang hao
qui a pas l'air d'être en grande forme
ouais je sais pas vous partie
intéressante dire qu il y ait une baisse
de - mais à trois pions le flou mais si
ça peut couper du jeu dur à dire je sais
pas trop qui est mieux pour moi je
préférais les blancs perso je pense non
georges aura envie d'essayer de faire
mais bon après si non quel à 5 et 6 4
le vide est finalement le quatrième vl
quoi très dangereux ben en dur à votre
avis
nv ne se qualifie pas aux candidats
continuera-t-il sa quête ultime du graal
dans deux ans va je pense oui fin il
continuera un peu mais bon autant qui se
qualifie quand même oui non enfin je
vois pas dire non j'arrête les échecs
non ou encore il remplace au pied levé
aronian ou radjabov fouet l'un des deux
ça c'est pas vraiment de kyle sandrine
qui remplace l'autre on sait pas on sait
pas qui est des prévenus en premier
choix se sentent souvent sombres eakin
qui était le premier remplaçant de rajab
du goût et bong est revenu après
traduite dominguez d'ailleurs que
l'apôtre intéresse l on peut le
comprendre à gao
comment je peux comment je peux ne pas
gagner contre navarre après déjà trois
parties très beau qui les flattent comme
coach et il lui remet quoi comment
battre papa aux échecs et à fond quoi
oui on avait sorti
il est sorti vite yougov un grand prix
devant ouais il peut faire des trucs
wyart il accueillera t + 5 bien ce que
je dis non il peut être dangereux mais
c'est bon quoi vous l'avez dit oui
j'avais perdu contre novara on n'avait
pas prévenu qu'il ne savait que calculer
quoi que mais qui doit leur revenir
le schéma il jouait en équipe soit en
équipe de france soit par équipe avec
tomsk-7 patrick lachaussée d'europe ça
doit être rsa tatum ski et voilà enfin
il s'est retrouvé contre navarra et les
coéquipiers n'ont pas prévenu qu'il ne
savait que calculer quoi va du coup ils
se retrouvent la femip au courant quoi
du coup ils peur oui il va après été
analysés avec lui je te rends compte que
le mec ça à peine bouger les pièces
quads ont été choqués quoi j'ai des
calculs très bien ton se fait plus très
bien vrai mais il avait raconté
l'anecdote mythique chez plus dans quel
ton astc talent estime que phil cup ou
quoi et tu as les joueurs qui parlent
des honoraires qu'ils ont eue pour
rejouer le ton est donc scellé caché
qu'ils ont pour participer au delà des
prix qui touche way est en net à navarra
il lève la tête et il ment damas mais
pourquoi il ya des honoraires à ce
tournoi 10 ou quoi bah c'est le sache
qui en avait pas quoi la détresse de
cette histoire il a répondu à chaque
fois non
pour n'avoir pas vraiment sympa quoi
tous des honoraires ça c'est beau donc
evra d'être content de son agent qu'il
réclame mais en fait on lui prend récent
% de ceux ci contre non non vous dira
rien pis nous pourrons a représenté quoi
du coup elles veulent si du coup cmv
elle gagne la prochaine partie le passe
au tour suivant way et si fait nul aussi
primitif et il aura les noirs mais ça
devrait aller non ouais ouais non mais
bon je vivais s'y est offert aux lignes
comme ça ne sera pas une petite news
direct mais ça peut être une victoire en
25 courses rien pourquoi y at il autant
chambrer renfort crise autant de tonnes
et n'en veut de moi j'en sais rien
exactement c'est flat quoi croire que
moi du coup c'est devenu un délire c'est
tout quoi mais après il est pas il a
alloué look il a quoi et ça va tu avais
dans le top 20 à 30 30 mondial peut-être
donc c'est quand même un très bon joueur
mais bon des fois ils ces pasteurs et
previ coup donc forcément pelade c'est
gravissime c'est rédhibitoire coiffe un
empêchement ça part vraiment du fait
qu'il ait battu la dent réalité enfin je
pense qu'il a de la bad puisse faire
passer quoi il aurait rien dit puis il
l'a battu d'un compte à régler c'est que
le calcul fans qui est mieux préparée
makau navarra bat normalement n'a qu'à
en fait un bond l'anac a récemment un
peu moins mais c'était quand même très
sérieux pendant très longtemps un accord
il navajos époque il est mal préparée
il est mal préparée contre l'élite tu
vas jouer contre les quatre scènes et
compagnie quoi mais comme on l'a vu chez
total a fait aujourd'hui aussi un
d'ailleurs mais quand une mais contre
des grands maîtres autour de 1700 - il
est juste beaucoup mieux préparés que
fais tu sais ça va crescendo
donc j'ai beaucoup moins bien préparés
qu'un mac steam mais il est beaucoup
mieux préparé que ben jarry maxime
lagarde par exemple si l'on prend les
deux maxime est ce que je pense qu'il
est mieux préparé que mathieu cornette
pas su quoi dire je sais pas
difficile à dire non à ceux mathieu
c'est quand même quand même très sérieux
il bosse beaucoup
fo a une qui dit on chambre à cause de
ça car okan légendaire on sait bien que
c'est pas un double oui mais en fait
c'est pas toi tu le sais ya beaucoup de
gens qui le sam est très difficile en
fait les mecs qui suivent beaucoup la
chaîne sont sur le sur le chat et où
vous le savez mais il ya vraiment des
gens parfois qui pensent qu'on est très
sérieux oui du coup on est obligé d fois
de tenir les mecs ont rigolé quoi fins
et c'est pour faire passer le temps
parce que les partis sont aussi longues
donc on est obligé de se trouver des
délires ah sinon un trait d quoi plus
serré que la chaîne existe depuis de
longues années et donc des délires
dessus depuis longtemps donc les gens
nouveau ça faut prendre au groupe c'est
pas évident mais on préfère on veut
faire un livre en fête avec ok le lot
minimum de culture à avoir pour suivre
la chaîne n'a pas raté du jeu et qui
pouvaient se voir sa peine bouger pièce
c'est fantastique série fantastique et
voit du coup sa dernière partie qui nous
intéresse vraiment mais bon on est quand
même plutôt pour huang dao qui sera un
adversaire plus difficile pour pour pour
mam et oui mais bon matin jean 5 avec un
dauphin en couverture à lui qu'il ya
compris à peine aujourd'hui que c'était
un délire qu'enfin fou après ils se
recroisent de croire at-elle débutant
dans ce tournoi qui sera jeudi au club
trop de jeunes s'est mis à jouer cette
salle crie de leur cru si ce n'est très
fort qu'en fait c'est un baudet l'ircam
a des airs de l'arize pour reprendre ça
m'arrivait bon alors on garde de bonnes
mares on en surface à navarra qu'en fait
que vlad a perdu moi j'ai déjà perdu
aussi conclu il ya longtemps en 2003 une
autre fois gibraltar et quelques années
y arrive a dit il est très fort contre
les 2006 vlad navarra lui il sait faire
mais bon des mecs vraiment vraiment nul
comme à claude sérillon
j'ai qui ne savent pas jouer du tout oui
il peut faire c'est son seul pouvoir
fort côté tonic matraque
qu'est ce que tu veux c'est normal quoi
comme ça autant des mondiaux il en ps a
répondu de la même voie mais la catillon
pour la pièce maman ouais mais il peut
perdre c'est le roi va concept faible et
saufs
c'est choquant parce que l'hiver avant
contre les débutants à 2006 ça passe
quoi ça va ça mais bon d'écouter au
moins de 1660 beaucoup plus dur c'est
quand même un héros qui tu passes dans
une autre catégorie quoi je penses tu ok
mais qu'est-ce qui fait non je pense
qu'il ya sept ans que le pedn se met à
jour où je sais pas quand tous les
joueurs ont terminé il ya une période de
repos minimum où il enchaîne dernière je
crois que c'est 15h30 un leur toit un
peu quoi on suivra ça mais voyons un
petit repos dan 17,3 et fuite
ouais c'est la position juste sous les
yeux et il a dix secondes lie à jouer
ses partenaires sont que tous les pgm
doit surtout ici de son ps que sur
felucia c'est un peu la place il y eut
de f3 jouer ici je pense que ça à faire
nul femme je vois pas comment non mais
ouais mais juste avec peu de temps la
pendule faut qu'il fasse gaffe parce
qu'il ya les cases noires et quelques
divers f5
ok présentait bien qu'alliés fin et où
je dire mais on va regretter un pion un
deuxième
voilà pour la peine pour dire du bien de
navarra pour une fois c'est vrai que ce
genre de position il peut très bien
jouer qui calcule vite justement ce
qu'on disait venir
et oui on comprend que c'est très
important que la dame f5 foot qua non
est ce que je retire ce que j'ai dit
qu'il ne comprend vraiment rien voilà du
coup c'est nul
sans les dames tu peux pas gagner
l'armée c'est compréhensible d'un
probable qu'il prend il à prendre des
quatre fous prendre la prendre b2 à tout
prendre vers nulle même avant tout ça
est donc donc le suspense continue dans
ce match sur l'identité du futur
adversaire de mam est bon simone et se
qualifie bien mission ah ouais mais du
coup pour l'instant donc max a gagné je
rappelle pour ceux qui viennent
d'arriver
de manière très convaincante très facile
il y a mais gagne aussi en fait né paul
kenny kong helfant des mam est abattu
yako les bons pose aussi où il veut
essayer mais bon tu vas pas si longtemps
la jante fosses étroite avance plus je
vois très bien qu'il ya en dessous on va
bouffer le pion à ce qu'on peut
qualifier la partie des mv oui on peut
en pourquoi pas peut-être on attend la
latence afin de salah a plus que ça va
faire pendant la pause donc peut-être
qu'ils ont posé nues accepté je sais pas
ce qu'il faut réfléchir à fond dans
cette opposition
non non non ça va faire nul à la pause
je vais très des vidéos
oui je vais
je veux dire préparer ça maintenant tu
vois je sais pas justement là grob fin
de set que je remette 2
ouais je peux remettre la grob les gens
aiment bien généralement oui moi je peux
pas trouver le titre comme ça on y avoir
que je retrouve les titres et tout bon
c'est pas gagné mais je veux faire ça la
pole en choeur ils osent y enfouir
nourrir de la finale de de navarin qui
viennent le roi des 5
mais oui donc les blancs peu pincé que
les blancs qui veut gagner
ouais c'est que les plans qu'ils peuvent
gagner mais bon ils vont pas gagner dans
l'autre côté droit des souks
ouais l'idée le truc musique / kg de 3
tu peux échanger et gagner le pion g3
donc forcément les bons peuvent pas
sinon ce serait une bonne nouvelle pour
eux des chevaliers non mais bon avec 10
secondes après en fait je sais pas on va
tous bords avaient un star à tout mais
moins on peut gagner en fait surtout ang
pas exception ou pas sur tout le monde
seuls loin qui d'autre comme ça j'ai
préparé les vidéos de la pause ça c'est
fait donc ouais ça chez quelqu'un peut
confirmer que ça commence continue bien
car il faut qu'on sente bien à 15h30
mais bon je les vois pas recommencer à
une autre heure en fait ce jour une
heure et demie et voilà ce que dit quand
on sait que philippe yacé sur les pions
mais bon tu fais ce rêve une barre une
les pièces mais oui c'est ça l'objectif
ça va être sacrifiée mais c'est pas si
simple pour un ordi c'est très simple en
fait mais avec dix secondes en pratique
il put en avait plein de choses que je
peux pas mettre les best of de ludique
sur la chaîne parce qu'en fait il ya
déjà des musiques copyright et des trucs
comme ça parfois alors ça passe sur
youtube parce qu'il des moyens utilisés
etc
mais là comme c'est pas ma chaîne perso
d'une compagnie ce qui en fait sur
youtube c'est paris c'est juste que
c'est copyright et du coup tu la
monétisation vao à l'ayant droit donc ya
pas de problème mais sur twitter comme
c'est du direct et tout ça si jamais un
problème ou quoi c'est un peu pénible
sur youtube tu peux juste mettre la
vidéo planifiée du coup tu vois qu'il ya
un copyright infringement mai et écrivez
un mail j'aurais dit oui ce n'est pas
grave parce que le fallait un endroit
pas juste il te prends la thune du coup
il est très content leurs ayants droits
huelskamp est au début les ayants droit
du coup ils te bloquer la vidéo et tu te
faisais un copyright infringement il
enlevait en fait en gros ne présente bon
rythme et abris lombrics sais quoi de ma
femme c'est typique inaugurant la
revente en faire quoi ça sert de façon
ça changerait quoi donc du coup
maintenant ils font ça et donc ils te
disent oui tout va très bien continuer à
utiliser la vidéo juste baraf tu n'auras
pas d'argent dessus montoison les
monotypes jamais non batta une pub
d'entrée en fait en général mais du coup
il aimait en fait du coup ils te mettent
plein de pub quand celles ayant droit en
fait celle ayant droit qui met les pubs
qui veut ça
mettre autant de tubes qui veulent
ayants droit fait c'est comme si la
vidéo elle appartenait à l'ayant droit
social aux ayants droit
bah du coup ils partagent entre ayants
droit quoi mais en fait appartient plus
vraiment à ce niveau là c'est eux qui
m'ont dit hitchcock comme il veut aller
qui font ce qu'ils veulent c'est vrai
attendent autre chose et moi j'ai pas de
bloc par exemple je vais pas par
solidarité mais c'est plutôt les blancs
qui jouent vraiment pour quelque chose
lui une ambition sur tous les plans
cheikh lors du dîner les bons c'est je
veux bien croire parce que c'est dur de
faire quelque chose mais tu te trompes
et un problème pour les blancs va-t-il
donc alliée fin elle a participé à
l'avancé des pions pour 10 cardini plus
nulle la banque fim aussi assis à pas de
chance parce que je suis un père pète
peut-être enfin obligé de reculer le roi
machin secrète je suis roi h 5 veux te
faire caillasser six échecs
oui parce qu'ils feront jusqu'à 300
places et 3g 6 ha bon au pire c'est pas
grave hein tu te fais bouffer des pions
comme ça à faire annuler ce qu'il tente
renom mais moins 80 parce que son but
qu'il a pas de risque de perdre pour
être arrivé c'est pas faux j'écoutais
beaucoup
donc ils ont fini la partie dry krishna
cardiaque
tout le monde a fait nul sauf ma mais
max et une époque
ouais savent ce qui avait le plus gros
la plus grosse différence de niveau donc
pensez vous que kara qui ne pouvait
stopper m'hamed
enfin c'est un sacré joueur que carrier
qui ou quoi mais mais bon il aurait
rendez-vous que en demi-finale alors je
sais pas ce qui peut se passer d'ici là
c'est beaucoup de choses qu'on a chance
tu es changement juste les bras les cinq
ça à faire nullement là c'est vraiment
nul nul nul nul c'est génial il a joué
avec et pour gagner michael orr il n'a
pas échangé il veut taper le pion à six
essais d'aller gagner g4 et faire un fou
cavaler contre cavaliers quoi est-ce que
posteriori car jaeckin et c'est un des
candidats au titre à la carrière la plus
nulle de l'histoire des échecs
fantastique les questions ben may cry
qui y performent
enfin je sais pas il s'était le plus fin
c'est toujours le plus jeune grand
maître de l'histoire et à 12 ans et 8
mois où sa personne pour lui enlever de
façon et ils coûtent ils définissent de
championnat du monde c'est pas tout le
monde qui a fait sa gloire genre à
rognan n'ont jamais quoi una caffin lamy
veut quand il veut et où il veut
comparer avec le palmarès des genres
justement qui ont fait finale de
championnat du monde
bah si l'on fait que finalement on fait
que finale quoi d'autre je sais par
votre bajaras que son palmarès est moins
bon que fut decarone pour l'instant ah
oui quand même
ben oui non quand même caruana ils
étaient 28
28 beaucoup oui mais bon là encore fait
premier ex-aequo de la head of men et
oui l'a fait quand même pas mal de trucs
les trucs c'est à paul ii finissent de
champions du monde font qu'elle finit
champion du monde oui ben alors les
derniers finale moi ok t'as un finaliste
pire je penserai quelle forme mais sinon
avant les playlists et des crown icahn
andris battait les uns les autres
topalov été finaliste sinon c'était
karpov qui est des finances charteau
sicap a une très grosse carrière du
short mais c'est rare en fait bon avant
c'était cochonnailles mais qui a une
longue carrière après vous voulez pas
des champions du monde mais genre space
qui a été champion du monde fisher et
des champions du monde peut être aussi
ont été champions du monde
oui is life bronstein n'a pas été
champion du monde et après c'est les
anciens quoi les mecs qui jouait contre
le vent peut-être le pire c'est
mais qui veut contrôler eakin roscoff
fatale bogoliubov à wii fit et personne
n'était pas terrible au goût du bois à
deux fois et quoi d'autre puis je sais
pas tout les janofsky mais comme ça quoi
si notre époque quelle est cette ces
jolies lavier jeu dont on ne te prends
pas tout mais c'est beau oui on les a
vraiment des heures et tout vlad serait
mort de rire non mais ils se bouffent
les cavaliers et ce beaucoup sur moi ce
que je sorte à une carrière courte car
beaucoup trop court à votre haïti
justifiable de continuer cette partie là
bas un printemps en poche
heynckes de plus quand même donc après
bombe à des blancs vont battre le filet
mais en fait pourquoi pas jouer tant que
tu peux pas t'en guerre ce qui serait
grotesque cécile et n'auront pas le
cavalier seul mais j'ai déjà partie par
k o les comptes jouer à fond pour ce
faire tomber zaoui une pression qui
existe tout mba d'accord c'est un crime
mais met ça en fait ok c'est juste
complètement nul
je peux jouer comme ça si le mec se
trompent disent maintenant des fils a de
la chance ça vient du fait que l'autre
que les jouets le truc avec trois pions
contre les deux pièces jusqu'au n'avoir
pas dû être content oui mais on peut
comprendre c'est ce qui l'a pas moi je
m'en voudras personnes se faisait sentir
je pourrais avoir les blanche serait pas
je serai pas énervé j'aurai le nord
serait pas une arme je serais déjà en
train d'essayer du tact inné la truffe
un enfant à le taper à ce qu'ils jouent
la pendule non il ya du rajout de temps
donc je suis enfin c'est pas une minute
52 pour ungaro maintenant donc tombera
demain ça va finir en mules ont fait
danser tarde pas à grand chose qu'ils
font mais mais mais il n'y a rien de
déplacé là dedans quoi c'est pas un
manque de respect quand je vois tu vas
manquer de respect non je t'ai pas
manquer de respect mais par match et le
droit de révoquer liste si tu m'as
manqué de respect non je ne te manque
pas de respect ou en ga au skins
deuxième partie way une deuxième partie
mais qui compte bientôt on pense un
allant vers 15h30
on n'est pas complètement sûr de l'orga
je vous respecter des horaires ou quoi
mais ça sera à peu près ça ouais c'est
vrai 15h30
surtout que la salle elle dure vraiment
longtemps deux parties pour la peine acs
a fait nul
bon alors du coup je vais en vitesse une
petite page de pub et à la sortie de la
page de pub je mets la pause
eh ben tu à l'heure tout le monde on va
encourager max à fond pour pour tenir la
seconde partie mais mais on est très
confiant ouais donc retour dans 15
minutes
je mets une pause va du coup la pause
les vidéos de pause durant un peu plus
fin
on les verra pas jusqu au fond ce que je
pensais qu'on aurait 25 minutes de pause
n'a que 15 mai je lance à l'efa va tout
de suite
magnus horrible au kg 4
boum tu dégages j'en ai rien à [ __ ] g
premier à grob
on a beau faire des 4,3 tout le tournoi
g4 on avait dit qu'on ferait je suis en
lannister je tiens parole au quai des
cinq projets de tu dégages hockey
commence à se structurer au kg 5
la taxe pike eu 5 des quatre med si tu
regardes ce truc là en replay c'est
total dédicace à toi tonton dédicace à m
dédicace à mai de la famille ok c 4
justin assez incroyable tu sais qu'on
dirait qu'il fut en train de jouer c'est
juste ouf
je suis juste en pls c'est pas plutôt un
jeu contre le champion du monde d'échecs
là quand même sa première fois dans ma
vie
bon ok les erreurs qu'on a fait c'est
prendre et 5 par le passé et je pense
qu'on voulait faire dam des trois assez
souvent
donc c'est ce qu'on va faire
c é rock indé joue pas mal de gamins
donc j'ai envie de faire h4 et d'aller
faire cavalier h3 et fouet f4 ok il veut
faire cavalier b4 ça on va lui interdire
on va faire à trois on va mettre le
cavalier acheron va jouer fouet f4
les mecs je pense qu'ils préparent un
sale coup je pense qu'il veut prendre
rendez-vous aussi se moquer c'est pas si
grave si prend prend fou aussi sauté on
va mettre la dame là sait pas s'il va
faire cavaliers affichent 3 on s'en fout
si fede 5 je fais ces cinq je m'en fous
total est ok s'il fait ça ce qui a
préparé depuis longtemps maintenant on
va lui faire c'est simple et on va
essayer de lui jouer à la main us en
fait je veux dire que son cavalier à six
est mal placée ok mais on va cet art et
par damas 4 il va faire dame c8 on va
faire b4 et on va continuer à jouer sur
son cavale qui est très mal placé et
peut-être après je ferai même cavalier
prend 2,3 et fouet f
ok on va faire b 4 ans protègent notre
pions en fait on est bien ok prise je
prends de b évidemment et maintenant je
veux juste être ok je vais encaissé une
fois attendait mais là il ya peut-être
un pur ans et 6 qui traînent quoi la
moitié on va prendre one time et on va
faire trois mois les mecs je pense qu'on
est bien parce qu'on menace fouet f1 en
fait et je pensais juste très très bien
en fait faut juste faire le vide dans la
tête on joue contre un mec lambda on va
lui défoncer sa mère désolé pour le
langage mais ok je me motive comme je
peux ok tours à huit dont qui prépare
cavaliers v8 mais je prends son pion c6
sur tarn français si sa foi cette [ __ ]
d'un procès 6 x 5 [ __ ] j'ai pas le
temps tous des fonds le complot c'est
pas manu soit 1 400 pour rien sinon dame
français 6 à gagner juste quoi est ok
c'est impossible de faire marcher ça ok
on reste calme
on fait fou d2 on développe et tour bien
je le prends la colonne un cavalier à
deux cavaliers b4 [ __ ] fabien le plan
de fabien m'a déjà parlé de sa cavale et
à deux cavaliers b4 c'était dans le
title tuesday dans un title fusée préfet
précédent ok il veut faire ça mon fou
est mal placé mais de façon il n'empêche
cavale et ados kébé 4 quelque part je
sais plus quoi faire
j'ai plus le mojo là
goethe être placé mon roi verser 2 ça je
suis pas sur l'espion là qui va être
mauvais
ok
en train de s'en tirer quoi mais
cavalivi ce qu'il a bien sauvé le truc
en train de nous menacer là ok on aura
malheureusement montré la grande bouche
champion du monde quand même
mais a le plus en f2 qui va rester en
prise il aura bien trouvé le tour à 8
j'étais pas loin de défoncer quand même
j'étais pas loin quoi bon aller on reste
concentré ok ils menacent ça il faut
protéger il faut 1 c'était l'idée de
base à temps si je fais qu'un mâle f4
[Musique]
ok je suis complètement ouf je vais
rentrer dans une grande technique contre
magnus on n'a pas peur ok j'ai calculé
jusqu'à quel point cette tour prend
c'est cette dame prend à saintes les
mecs j'ai vu ça jusque là et je me suis
que sa tour faut être dans la merde
après l'action prend ici aussi qui est
chiant ok mais on n'est juste pas mal
encore je ressens je veux les meilleurs
échec de ma vie quoi j'ai jamais joué
comme ça c'est vous qui en gardent
confiance on a joué la tour en f1 fait
juste une bonne partie pour le moment et
comme ça on n'en sera peut-être fou
aussi d'apprendre à me prend et tous
réfutent mat
ok ce faire un truc qui va vous paraître
dingue je peux apprendre son cavale et
c'est peut-être un crack afssa
j'étais juste de craquer
[ __ ] j'ai pas vu assez loin [ __ ] je
n'ai pas vu assez loin fait chier
juste en aura été bien content magnus
quand même
il veut obtenir la casse des cinq sont
cavale et il va menacer cavale b4
replace la dame 24 secondes
je tiens tout maintenant foire et
l'enflure b2 je tiens encore pouvait 2
j'avais pas vu encore en vie quoi c'est
un miracle et gdf cet hymne à ce qu'il
voit bien il va prendre en b2c obligé
c'est juste complètement gagnant il
objet de prendre en b2 est ok c'est
juste complètement gagnant bon
maintenant il faut pas de choc ce qui va
pas être le plus évident [ __ ]
je suis en train de choc les mecs
je suis juste en train d'être chaud
contre magnus carlsen
quand je suis déconnecté liasse on a
fait nul contre marseille on a fait du
[Musique]
buzz est juste ou c'est juste dingue
c'est juste dingue c'est juste
complètement what the fuck watford les
mecs
qu'est ce qui vient de se passer on a
juste choc contre quinzaine [ __ ] c ur
faisons c'est juste vous non mais
j'hallucine
j'étais complètement gagnant enfin c'est
juste complètement dingue ça c'est juste
ouf dingue
j'hallucine quoi j'ai juste pas perdu
comme carlson bonjour à tous et à la
femme c'est reparti déjà déjà reparti
quoi
plus que prévu ouais ouais ouais c'est
difficile avec ces horaires tu peux
jamais vraiment savoir lors de reprise
donc petit 9 nov
il n'a pas fait nul mais il aurait pu
répéter que de ça qui a aimé trois
différentes avec il faut deux pour
essayer de faire crisser quatre
cavaliers 3 mais je ne sais pas ce qui
est des deux sites
tu pense qu'il a une petite idée ou
c'est l'autre en fait
bah c'est pas absurde dans ce genre de
situation donc et c6 que c'est hyper
assez dans le jeu comme sport s'était
joué que deux fois dans la base sur des
dizaines de milliers de parties il va
vouloir faire quoi cavaliers f1 car il
ya eu 3 ou cavani c4 pareil non mais
s'était jouée par aucun joueur à plus de
2000 locaux normal que j'ai pas
spécialement
michael mathieu tu aurais dit oui mais
bien sûr j'ai analysé dans mon fichier
sera sage entraînement sur cette période
donc et des deux pieds et ses six bombes
un couteau tf1 j'imagine ça sent pas le
danger dans cette histoire non mais
c'est une position normale en fait les
blancs de suite vous sur le gaz partie
l'on croyait pas mais je m'attends à
être plus je m'attendais plus à une
variante avec fu g5 ou quelque chose de
ce type là je pense que vous serez
c'était la théorie là-dessus ni vu un
trou juste un truc qui joue quoi mais da
silva a pu et cf3 quoi oui je sais pas
ces structures avec quoi s'inquiéter
j'ai reçu que maxime et joue tellement
bien que je suis plutôt content du choix
un après mais je suis d'autant plus je
suis encore plus confiant qu'avant la
partie en fait non mais en fait je suis
pas très inquiet mais je veux dire je
sais pas là le choix aux appels arriver
aux gens c'est un vin je pensais pas
table comme variante 3 quand même là on
fait un vrai dire mais ok pourquoi pas
tu pensais juste pas de bons choix en
fait by a aucun choix évident tu peux
repartir pour l'ong laisse peut-être
sinon ouais ça lui a rapporté quelques
résultats et maxime a dû préparer
oui mais tant pis 28 entre mais là c'est
ce qu'il faut si pas pourquoi on va te
c'est pas pire pas mieux qu autre chose
en tout cas ça a l'air salars très
tranquille pour maxime surtout caïques
et caprica et des deux donc surprise de
topalov il ajouté alice et sissoko qui
est quand même le plus logique et
topalov qui est déjà plus dans la prépa
au palmarès de la surprise je me suis
surpris moi même quoi fêter ses 4
donc qui aura lieu 3 qui arrive et qui a
aidé 5 qui va venir nous a donc opté de
faire à 6 pour vider les fous g5
pourquoi pas sur un coup que je
considèrerai ici sinon tu peux faire
peut-être b5 comme celle qui lie part 2
ou 3 et fait faute si elle avait les
clés des quatre fous des trois tempo
j'ai des gars c'est pas un coût auquel
je m'attendais fab bon pourquoi pas en
faute mais ouais non mais peut-être
aussi
non je sens bon c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'il pense et si ça vaut peut être
c'est pour venir en d4 mais bon l'idée
des blancs du coup ses rangs quelques
trois cavaliers cédé 5 et peut-être c3
pour pour chasser le caribou dans un
deuxième temps mais les noirs mettront
le fou en russie ce pour bien colmaté la
casse des cinq voies et puis le caillou
ce qui peut des fois les ans aussi
suisse lui-même et rebondir vers c'est
ça un coup au f4 je sais pas il aura
fait un sacré chemin pour arriver à ces
cinq sets mais des fois t'es gênés en
fait pincé d'aplomb des six qui doit
couvrir ou des choses comme ça m'en fous
des trois à jouer maintenant c'est
maxime qui prend qui prend son temps il
a raison il veut bien peser le pour et
le contre et ci commence parfois aussi
c'est ce qu'ils gardent la case aux six
pour le cavalier ce qui fait rock et ce
qu'ils jouent b5 pour mettre le fou en
baisse est éventuellement il a quand
même beaucoup d'options qui s'offrent à
lui femmes - clairement une autre option
c'est aussi d'essayer de prépa des cinq
bons latins de cinq ans meurent mais un
coup kamdem c7
ouais mais d'écouté par mois des cinq
noms mais peut-être qu'à force mais
juste c'est quand même clairement une
poussée que tu aimes bien faire dans ce
genre de situation est ce que les blancs
par envie de faire rock et f4 ouais si
on leur laisse
le cavaly sekkat surtout on fait le fou
g4 ouest peu battus provoqué l'effroi
qui jamais fou pour le met enfin est-ce
que ça fait bien plus agrandi à 7 juin
et de 2 tu veux qu alliage 5 pour venir
vérifie 4 bat du coup de contrôle plus
la case ou f4
ça fait 3 passes j'ai pu la dame bien
qu'ils défendent à 15 h 5 ouais d'accord
tu vois c'est le fonds s'est vite tu
joues jeux maquillage 5 tu veux dire que
là quand tu fais ça tu peux faire
cavaler h simple parce qu'à pas d'âme
pour acheter
bon peut-être pas si tôt mais en tout
cas clairement c'est un truc un jour
dont café f3 il faut aussi ce cavalier 3
quasi quasi tempo
ok donc bon déjà des cinq ça doit se
regarder et maxime qui est peut-être en
train d'égaliser en force un fab basse
d'être mieux qu'égaliser en fait parce
que le gf3 que nous dit l'ordi à peu
près égale à peu près égale des 5 paraît
quand même assez logique un side en
profiter tout de suite
bah ouais tu te laisses pas fixée bon ok
il ya le père de flou c'est pas grand
chose non non c'est vrai mais c'est pas
d'être drôle quoi ça joue nos petits un
petit peu quand même un petit peu mais
alors on diffusera nul il prendra pas de
risques c'est sûr que si maxime un peu
faire nul il fera nul hein ça c'est sûr
qu'il va pas cyril qu'il est courageux
topi de rentrer dans la nageur de contr
e maxime lors qu'ils en meurent swing
mais tu voulais qu'il fasse quoi
en réalité que pouvait-il faire d'autres
batailles robe quand même bref haye
moi je trouve qu'il a hélas il a fait le
choix logique hein y'a pas il ya rien de
surprenant là dedans non membres et
toutes les ouvertures étaient possibles
il y en a pas une qui a l'air a priori
mieux donc aux jouets le nageur pourquoi
pas comme une ouverture de combat là
nadjaf
tu peux chercher un truc dans la
grünfeld à essayer de l'embêter je sais
pas c'est une petite ligne ou un truc tu
fais vite h4 ou je sais pas quoi une
anglaise pourquoi pas mais la neige d'or
ce qui me rassure de combat donc tu en
as pas une partie nulle part nul direct
ou quad non le choix le choix le choix
est tout à fait tout à fait logique et
compréhensible en plus il a tenté un
petit coup pour sortir de la théorie on
a on a bien vu fait qu'il n'était pas à
l'aise dans la théorie justement donc
tout semble tout semble logique du côté
bulgare maintenant maxime tellement
impérial sur cette nage d'or fab déjà
contre les joueurs du top niveau mondial
là on est quand même en droit d'espérer
que ça se passe bien non mais bien sûr
ce devrait bien se passer sa chance par
noter que quoi qui se passe aujourd'hui
on pourra pas on pourra pas sabrer le
champagne puisque wesley so pourrez
toujours gagner le tournoi avec les
bonus et sortir maxime bouet une façon
crédit depuis plusieurs jours ouais quoi
qu'il en soit mais je le rappelais quoi
qu'il en soit demain on sera là de
nouveau à 14 heures c'était toi pour
faire une petite transition par rapport
à ça nous pour suivre les parties que
maxime soit qualifié pas qualifiés
facois qui se passe en fait demain ça ça
continue quoi mais nous passons devant
comment toi tu me connais pas d'autres
possibilités mais va même si mam et et
puis cette façon la pression sera là
puisque puisque puisque rien ne sera
décidé ce soir en revanche il pourrait y
avoir une décision fait dans le week end
fab
peut-être bien kloten bien possible que
peut-être pas dimanche puisqu'ils
pourraient avoir des partages pour les
autres mais peut-être bien que lundi
soir on aura déjà notre note max
qualifiés pour les candidats une taupe
qui qualifie pour le tour suivant les
éleveurs qui les qualifie pour les
candidats c'est déjà pas mal
donkey laroquais topalov qui devrait
rauque et lui aussi
non tu peu rauque et en fait parce que
des 5 c'est plus un coup vu cura c'est
rohff princes attend la fin tu peux
rockets
non mais j'ai tu peux toujours ok mais
je veux dire sur roc des normes peuvent
pas louer des cinq sets est ce que tu
fais prise et à ses trois ris pris ces
trois donc et si maxime et en 2000 est
ce que max et est-ce que voici peu le
rattraper je crois pas ben je sais pas
comment tu me manques de points quand en
trois temps mark iii
amélie pour attraper s'il fait faux bond
aux news
le bug bonus par heikki et en afrique
bonus ça devient difficile
mais bon qui sait bon ok on dit que mam
et à blender alors attends c'est quand
même intéressant alors qu'émilie coton
foudres de jeu saint mamet mais non mais
il peut faire nul en fait oui c'est ce
qu'on appelle une grille de choc trapel
à fait la même contre dominguez en coupe
du monde et il avait perdu dès regret
tout cas quesnoy mais en fait c'est pas
je suis pas sûr sauve l'honneur du tout
enfin c'est juste très chaud mais ses
traits et hautement de soucis de
variantes au lieu d'une eau de
tranquille après si on a dit que c'était
un joueur qui a besoin de se chauffer ma
mais fait il a juste besoin de ça pour
pour son tournoi existe 70 et oui mais
bon par un bon enfin autre convive très
compliqué bon on rappelle que ce soit
maxime ce soit ma mais que ce soit n'est
peau même si perdre cette partie de
façon les départage continue noms qui
peuvent ils sont quelque part protéger
d'élimination et maxime qui vous calez
décès dont qui prépare l'arrivée du
cahier verser 5
j'imagine fab tue aussi tu vois le
passage à ton fawcett verger 5 notamment
pour éventuellement venir s'échanger
c'est plutôt ton flou demeure donc on va
voir mais qui est restée trois des cinq
devrait être logique
et la prod fait ces trois peut-être way
topalov qui jusqu'à maintenant a joué
assez vite
il lui reste encore 23 minutes maxime 19
minutes
les deux joueurs qui jouent vite j'ai
envie de dire à d'ailleurs c'est un
petit peu avancé t il céder 5 fu g5
je pensais 3 ben ouais ben pourquoi pas
faire maxime est reparti avec le
cavalier exactement non c'est une potion
fond de court peut-être b4 quand je
fouille b2 ouais ou à 4 fixé un peu les
ailes dame sait pas trop ce que tu fais
quoi mais foutez de touche et adam tu
mettais tout enfin tu vois quoi tu vas
tu écriras c'est dur d'être actif qu'on
sait comme ça tu as un peu vissé à
l'oreille est grave parce que moi en
fait j'en ai joué pas mal des positions
de kalach ou depuis on s'est trop avancé
4 et charles cailleux 3 il vient il
reste en c2 pourquoi tu es en d4 avec
l'autre jaro québec b4 juste on peut
illustrer fekkai ces deux avec les
blancs bizarre genre français un temps
français un coup lambda tour c'est vital
et ces quatre géants position j'ai eu
assez souvent en fait tu fais pas grand
chose avec les noirs mais c'est dur avec
les blancs de faire un truc aussi quand
même c'est là qu'est née marthe a juste
besoin de faire est de 5
ben tu construire des trous partout et
ses îles et blanc qui ont profité du rsa
est un pion arriérés des 6es compagnie
enfin c'est pas dans l'air du temps là
mais t'as pas en plein air qui fait que
les noirs mais juste en face il est
blanc et blanc font les idiots tu vas tu
viens tu pas de local ans et cinq jeux
pc de préparer b5 parfois si tu peux
mais seulement quand même les blancs
contre mais du coup chacun c'est un peu
un jeu de faïence que tu as un chien de
faïence
parce qu'à la position en arriver
jusqu'à ces trois cas et ses six comme
tu l'avais prévu mais la tunise et
peut-être p 4
alors ça je sais pas mais tu peux le roi
des rois chain tu peux tu faire plein
coup en fait juste sous des deux fous
ces deux peut-être prophylaxie comme 58
ans et cinq teintes à créhen
mais ouais même à quatre peut-être je
sais pas énormément d'options pour les
blancs qui semble a repris un petit plus
quand même fab une impression mouais
mais c'est pas grand chose nous dit
qu'il ya une coupe plus du rouge glossy
oui non mais en fait c'est juste très
compliqué comme position je suis même
pas sûr que leur disent de chess bon
bout quoi soit c'est bon pour pour
comprendre que c'est rouge ou pas rouge
il n'a pas le bon code couleur non non
il donnait un peut-être femme il a joué
cette fameuse variantes de l'italienne
où tu joues tu en vois pas ces fameuses
variante à alhama mais justement non
mais lui il est à l'aise dans une
position très claire il avait gagné une
belle contre maxime d'ailleurs avec les
noirs ouais mais ce n'était pas tout à
fait la même mais oui c'était un mec hg
s'accroît avec l'âge c'est ce g5 avec le
foin fuite mais c'est dans le même
esprit dans un esprit à et juste comme
ça un dépôt oui par curiosité
l'époque est en difficulté quand même en
plus ou moins toutes les parties mais
qui est où là non mais ils sont pas du
tout en contrôle les mecs c'est fou le
s'il donnait peu de ma mais c'est quand
même mais c'est un peu tout ou rien
ouais haye ajoute cette variante là
n'est que du boeuf doivent faire jouer
dans les grands prix déjà qui est
intéressant dans fait mais c'est vrai
quand john vernile qu'en fait pas pareil
c'est extraordinaire oui c'est vraiment
tout ou rien bah c'est tout s'il sera
tous comme il l'a fait roi a chargé je
voulais en parler mais j'ai oublié ça
peut aussi être un coût intéressant
femme lily dans toutes les listes on
veut très suggestives et tous les coups
possibles mais oui c'est assez logique
quand on vote se déroule de nos jours
je suis dit que j'avais fait un instinct
coup très très rouge en mai un rouge
fluo après comme je dis femme ça peut
aussi être intéressant si si pour les
joueurs qui ont besoin de se chauffer
comme ça qu'ils ont besoin de prendre la
forme de jeu les deux parties bien
compliqué comme ça c'est toi c'est
peut-être une stratégie plus long terme
en fait ils regardent peut-être pas
juste la partie suivante et hagarde
peut-être le tournoi et guide il faut il
faut que je réussisse à faire une partie
tu as une partie référence quoi ouais
enfin rejoindre se passe je trouve ça
soupçonnant com est-il passé pour anish
giri la finul dans la première voilà je
me sens bien perdre la deuxième
personnelle non en fait je sens qu'il
envie de rentrer chez lui juste
d'arriver de noël quoi faut pas donc le
look de jeune on croit h à jouer et on a
une pré-liste un peu des joueurs
présents championnats du monde
rapide et blitz way presque je sais y'a
tout le monde qui va mais je ne sais pas
en fait c'est quoi le délire de toujours
mettre ce truc pour noël page beckham
plein de gens qui s'arrange pas de jouer
de chaque 25 décembre
du 26 au 30 oui mais du coup tu dois
venir et le 25 juin tournoi à 30 km de
chez toi c'est ton sec 26 ça va tâter 24
au soir
peut-être en famille quoi et 25 très
tonkinois les et tu peux aller jouer
quoi mais ce qu'a fait chaque n'aura pas
il a gagné tout tous les adversaires de
maxime ont gagné sauf tous peur mais je
sais pas après le calendrier tellement
chargé que c'est difficile de
j'ai croisé vidéo 6 janvier par exemple
cheval je prends juste des dates au
hasard qui ont la même durée quoi bon
enfin ce n'est pas seulement sera un
titre de champion du monde en tout début
d'année c'est vrai que c'est plus
logique de mettre en fin de saison je
sais pas non mais moi je m'en fiche je
vois ils font ce qu'ils veulent
wei à tata steel aujourd'hui mais c'est
plus vers le 20 ou le 15
axa reprend le 15 la saison après donc
bon droite passe dix ont décidé des
dates noël je le serai tranquille quoi
son fils 31/12 peut-être mais en gros et
bah du coup tu fais championnats du
monde début janvier et puis ça finira il
ya bien une saison presque tour a changé
le truc et c'est tout mes débuts j'ai
enlevé ça me paraît très bizarre quand
même pour un championnat du monde mais à
mais il m lemaitre en juin ou quoi
pourquoi pas ah oui mais enfin je veux
dire juste là dans les dates qu'on a
autour autour de chine c'est tous les
ans les championnats du monde de rapides
et blitz as we r eacu ni le chauffeur du
monde le vrai entre guillemets c'est
tous les deux ans pour qu'ils ramènent
un bon je sais pas qui va regarder le 26
décembre et 26 décembre c'est mieux
quand même d'un point de vue c'est quoi
des fonds sont aussi décembre deux jours
nancy si fin de six descentes pas des si
mauvaise date en soit c'est période de
vacances suis passé un peu les le 26
décembre talent boxing d'état genre de
choses je n'ai pas le 26 décembre ça
maintenant mais en soit ça ne paraît pas
être une mauvaise date après c'est plus
avec l'accumulation des tournois puisque
la soleil finit certains points
importants et fils 23 tu recommences le
26 c'est une certaine accumulation quoi
donc et ses quatre cavaliers fils comme
intéressant ça comme maxi donc été hissé
quatre français un prix c'est un
cavalier fils pour défendre des sites
web pour défendre des six est peut-être
la liste calculé dès qu'ils aient des
baies si ce n'est pas plutôt le subsea
cavalli cv 6 mai 2e les faucons de son
plan et sur cavaliers pros f6 d'un
problème si ce qui est prendre ici je
m'habille à tour cédé 8
quoique peut-être b cette emprise ici
c'est vrai ça peut être une idée le
stupre angel ouais midi où cavaliers ou
trois je reviens mais ça joue ça pour
les blancs j'équilibre 9,6 dom premier
fils ces crimes plus logique qui prend
des six du goût fort pour ses sautes
l'homme qui avait laissé quatre
lors des sept tours des huit dames 2 et
cavaliers 3a c'est peut-être ça l'idée
tour des huit dames 2 à tours 17 et
peut-être foubert fou s'éclate dame ses
quatre tours d2 comme je sonne de
monsieur propre
ces idées j'imagine non on va regarder
avec l'ordi cavaliers système m6 qui est
des six tours c'est cette crise et 4 n'a
détourné le jeu va tordre et 8am tueur
d'élite chez kiabi six caisses pénible
ça ok n'est donc ouais mais vous
assureront la partie
il n'y a pas fait b5 les blancs doivent
aller chercher le pion qui avait b6
quand même et il récupérera de ben ça va
oui mais bon ça joue enfin ce bord mais
oui toi ça devrait ça va être le
scénario de la partie on rejette un
petit ayama mais je voulais donner pour
ça parce qu'ils jouent que les betis ou
cavaliers tronche pas quoi attendiez
vous prenez 5 et d'échangés qui la tête
5e essai juste parfait présence tu as le
mauvais fruits que les blancs il n'y a
pas de défauts de structure enfin se
passer même même plus seuls et les noirs
qui joue la gagne après donc on est
obligé de prendre si on va jeter un oeil
à aux autres donc on avait galfond dhs
contre nez peau quelle partie de ce don
compliqué très compliqué on va pas on va
pas trop s'attarder dessus ou g5 vrai
mais dépôts qui prend vraiment tous les
risques et mam et emma mais ma mère m'a
même à mai
mam est compliqué ici chez pas au jeu
mais on peut pas dire en un coup d'oeil
co fois ci dessus et bien appelé scheer
nora on va rester sur maxime mais c'est
quand même une manière de jouer
intéressante pour eux pour les
adversaires directs de maxime donc qu'à
relief si ce sont les mecs je joue bon
il joue juste aux échecs
ils font abstraction du contexte certes
comme c'est pas pareil de lune parti
pour faire une ou deux jeux pour gagner
tu as tu choisi pas forcément le même
variante c'est autre chose quoi oui
c'est autre chose
aujourd'hui match de foot tu as gagné le
match aller 1-0 est ce que le retour tu
joues à que cinq attaquants quoi enfin
je sais pas je m'en fous je te mets ça
six attaquants maintien d'armes et
peut-être fin que je suis c'est poitiers
et je me perds dans tous les cas je me
dis défenseur c'est pas le problème mais
même tête ils ont besoin de ça comme
jeudi pour se mettre en forme les deux
ils n'ont pas super bien joué et ce
qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont juste envie
de se débrider quoi regarder quoi soit
réduit bridant où il sera très déprimant
oui je veux juste pas pour faire nuage
perturbe le sait bien qui est ce toi ok
bon je pense ou mac se faire [ __ ] en
d5 et qu'une bonne position mais du coup
se passait bien il a bien calculé sur
lequel preuve si ce qui est prend des
systèmes pas une décision simple et puis
là je t'aime pas aussi facile à jouer
quasi tempo nature ennuis dans le
château mans ils sont pas pleutre non
sans vous pas le hockey c4 alors je
dirais qu'il ya 17 ou donc les 17 j'aime
bien tu prépares médecin qui est tu
contrôles un peu les cases noires et là
oui oui qu'est qu'yvan que à +1 50 oui
mais c'est pas étonnant jeu disposition
on va tendre vers l'auto finale et puis
on vous pourrez commenter
en tout cas maxime c'est celui qui gère
le mieux pour le moment le tournoi
relais les autres que soient les pots ou
mam et c'est beaucoup plus poussif que
maxime qui m'a l'air d'être sûr de lui
encore que dans la première partie il
aurait pu il aurait pu il aurait pu
passer par la fenêtre
je ne surfe pas sur le preneur ce qui le
jeu le début ouais il aurait pu il
aurait pu il aurait pu y passer mais
toute cette saison et là quand même
il a quand même la réussite avec lui
maxime et j'ai envie de dire je vois pas
pourquoi ça ça s'arrêterait maintenant
non mais de the hill dans ces matches
comme ça il est géré quand même pas mal
il a un très bon taux de victoire c'est
vraiment très loin les grands prix sauce
pas mal enfin c'est un format qui va
bien il sait bien les gérer
oui oui c'est un format qui convient
parfaitement aux joueurs français
d'ailleurs c'est marrant qui est deux
tournois qualificatifs aux candidats la
coupe du monde et les grands prix qui
informe a complètement différent des
candidats c'est assez étrange en soit
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait s'attendre à
un mois je préférerais que ce soit ce
format même aux candidats un peu partout
j'adore ce format c'est un peu marrant
d'utiliser un format différent pour les
qualifications et pour pour le tournoi
final final ça assez rare mais bon tant
mieux un oui je sais pas quoi dire non
mais c'est dur de trouver qu'on se
qualifie pas les choses différemment et
après les candidats oui c'est vrai que
les matchs sympas mais les tournois sont
cool aussi original géorgien les
tournées quand ils ont tous été écoulés
récent bien sûr mais jarre le juré que
53 qui est légendaire ben c'était un
tournoi des candidats simplement fait
est donc très souvent c'est intéressant
le quai russa au 62e
[Musique]
grâce à la casse et au brésil oui je
pense
brazil c'est beau
non mais du coup c'est un côté
historique aussi de faire le format
tournera enfin et c'est plutôt du beau
jeu donc c'est pas les matches c'est
bien aussi n'ai-je pas feinte
ok j'ai pas d'avis tranché quand les
deux nouveaux cargos qui demande si je
suis heureux de la journée mondiale des
échecs vous écoute c'était déjà la
journée des échecs le 20 juillet de la
fidh donc je pense pas que ça change
grand chose
franchement je suis pas bon je gémis la
news sur twitter parce que ça me fait
marrer mais je pense ça changera rien en
soi
non mais beaucoup de cuir ce juste enfin
tant mieux un donc ce n'est pas normal
c'est ne pas pouvoir se qualifier en ne
jouant que des parties lentes sauf
unique place aux points elo alors si
ceux qui ont joué live man ils sont
qualifiés aux candidats seulement par
les mongols c'est qu'avec qualifiés
seulement par les parties longues balles
et c'est vrai que si tu suis assez
d'accord avec ça c'est pas très logique
de d'avoir de tournoi à élimination où
tout se joue sur les rapides pour en te
disant que les parties longues c'est le
summum et qui ont fait que le
championnat du monde en partie longue
etc
je trouve ça c'est vrai un petit peu
étrange d'utiliser des formats de
qualification qui favorise largement les
joueurs qui sont bons en longs gants
rapide pardon
malgré soi c'est un peu bizarre un petit
peu enfin pas un double langage quoi
saluer le grob très bon pseudo devrait
donc aider cette il va revenir vers ses
seins il va sûrement jouer avec des 3a
3b 4 topalov essayer de créer du jeu
allèles dame a le truc les blancs vous
et si tout ça mais je reste ici les
normes férec 5
et voilà moi c'est genre besoin j'aime
beaucoup que les noirs ça peut
ressembler aux machos partie du match
car le cndd caruana pour ceux qui
l'avaient suivi
en fait oui oui et non car cette
caravane c'est bien fini en rapide aussi
et karen carney clean aussi d'ailleurs
mais du coup le tour à des candidats au
milieu et il est il est un peu bizarre
non mais ok c'est pas de chance à ce
soit fini en repli de 4,5 à rona et tout
ça enfin c'est un peu le gisti seront
quand même 12 parties lentes
bon ben je trouve qu'ils se départagent
pas en 12 parties mais quoi dire moi
j'aurais bien vu alors soit tu m'as non
un perdre parti et je sais pas
soit soit tu non mais pour les candidats
moi j'aurais bien vu des matches en
quatre parties tu vois bon après quarts
de finale demi-finales la finale tête en
six parties au final ça te fait 4 suite
que c'était 14 parties cette faute en
deux parties mais je sais pas non enfin
pourquoi pas un vote ne me dérangerait
pas qu'ils le fassent tu diras pas oui
c'est scandaleux surtout fois pourquoi
pas mais je suis jamais vraiment des
sujets tandis candidat donc ça me va
aussi
on verra si tu l'as qui nous ce qu'ils
nous réservent wii music et se trouve il
sera pour rire mais c'est parce que une
fois ces poltrons doit tout remettre en
cause
si c'était tout le temps de la merde bon
on va dire ça va mais là en fait la
dernière fois c'était sympa après tout
dépend quel sont tes critères aussi un
show le londres en 2013 était chauffeur
et du suspense jusqu'à la dernière ronde
quoi je veux dire c'est pas des trucs
comme ça il est pas mal de parties bien
ouais après à faire quand même toujours
les formats coupin personnellement pour
le public c'est quand même plus plus
compréhensive les plus plus dynamique
que quand tout le monde vous compte tout
le monde
enfin moi je mettrais tout temps rapide
en fait de base mais à mais quitte à
garder les parties longues
je trouve c'est plus lisible un format
avec des quarts de finale demi finales
finale mais losc est bizarre c'est que
tu fais tout ça pour rien n'est encore
joué un match au bon vouloir tuer le
champion du monde de dents qui rentre
qu'un certain tour
genève un truc comme ça mais en fait ce
qu'ils veulent aussi absolument faire un
match pour le titre à la fin et avec le
champion du monde qui a quand même
beaucoup de privilèges
on sait pas pourquoi d'ailleurs
nombreuses historiques voudraient qu'on
pourra un jour décidé que ben c'est bon
bah tu as déjà été champion du monde
c'est déjà ça ton prix village en fête
déjà là mais comme au foot des champions
du monde sont quand même passer les
barrages maintenant avant un bon étaient
qualifiés d'office maintenant c'est même
plus le coeur mais tu as des pâtes
qualifie d'office pour la finale au foot
tu reprenait en poule 4 ans plus tard
après c'est difficile de te comparer le
collectif et individuel mais bon ça
pourrait repartir justement fait tu
pourras voir caruana lé finaliste qui
est pas qualifié du tout à rien et le
champion du monde qui est qualifié au
truc en quarts de finale et du coup tant
à cet autre qui se battent pour entrer
dans le truc et je suis proche du monde
il rentre en quart ça me choque fait pas
spécialement quoi au chaud que de rien
bonsoir bord du coup c'est pas en la
structure que je pensais il n'a pas joué
5 avec les normes axe et du coup thomas
faudra profiter pour f4 lui même ouvrir
un peu le jeu ce qui est bien pensants
fou après prêtait une belle caisse dans
le cinq quand même pour un cavalier mais
faut faire gaffe si les blancs arrive à
faire à troyes b 4 il y avait sûrement
tuer d'abord b3 machin tu peut cumuler
un peu les problèmes sur les droits avec
le foot bien qu'il concède bien placé
ouais ça peut être celui dangereux non
j'ai tendance à me voyait alors à voir
mais c'est pour l'instant ce pas
d'inquiétude mais je sais pas j'ai un
peu fait avoir un pur avec 5 et mais bon
peut-être que je sois toi tu es gamin
joueurs naturel de cette structure de
pions puisque tu l'as dans tes dents tu
es kalach bombe et maxime aussi il n'ya
souvent que j'aurais dû faire confiance
et magnus on a aussi beaucoup eu
dans le mât champagne mumm justement de
ton parler karlsson caruana donc c'est
une structure qu'on a souvent eu
l'occasion de voir et c'est vrai que
généralement les noirs jouent plutôt
avec pardon vous plutôt avec f5 et sur l
oratrice essaye de faire eux quatre ils
avaient peur de se prendre au jeu 4
j'ai passé ma non plus d'armes non c'est
vrai que ça faisait peur j'ai quatre
coups magiques non mais non c'est
vraiment une idée du genre de pression
tu pètes f5 du coup tu gagnes ou quatre
ans j'ai eu florent je suis pas du tout
inquiets fab
on rejette un oeil aux deux autres yako
qu'est ce que c'est que ces lunettes
même position je mets les vals parce que
sinon vous bon les valides c'est mieux
pour les blancs donc il faut juste
pokémon dans l'aval de m + 2 pour yacco
galfond de mes points forts des fous
furieux avant bon là là alors dit oui
les noirs sont mieux bon c'est pas
possible
enfin l'aïe et chacun déjà paris mais
écoutons vernon il reste 21 minutes à
des posters que s'ajoutent ou tempo
assez bonne épouse c'est un autre
concept né pauvre alors parti en f1 et
que sa tour je sais pas je pensais
qu'ils reviendraient vers f3 pour
doubler et peut-être partir en g3 ben en
fait au moins un f2 enfin je sais pas
enfin tu deviens l'option double tour
dans sa tombe bien j'avais j'ai 4 au 6
mai s'avère logique widow d'essayer de
faire un truc a le droit et que les
tours oui une tour au mondial
enfin une vraie taille puisque tu
voulais ramener l'autre croit clairement
enfin tuer m les deux tours chrétienne
il appelle tempo ni achi c'est ça le
champion du monde rentre en car ils
peuvent même pas lui payer un taxi
l'écrit chrome ce trotteur 40 alors ils
peuvent pas y sont fauchés quoi ils ont
de la fièvre ou quoi ils sont ils
sourient sont énervés des poèmes et mam
effet scout c'est en eux au moins ils
prennent le risque de
pas de sortir pour le moment mais en
tout cas de continuer le match et de
devoir aller dans une cadence plus
rapide des pertes de l'influx nerveux
mais côté maxime s'est pas fait non plus
non mais vous écoutera maxime si tu
normal ce qui se passera c'est plus en
contrôle mais s'est pas fait mais c'est
pas fait ni aux pans de bois coûte il un
peu mieux même dame g5 pas mal clou un
peu le cavalier aux 3 et puisque le clou
elle a en fait quoi de plus cool plus
bas mais tu dis coup un peu jusqu'à 20h
jusqu'à un peu mais on ne peut que louer
un palmarès suivent ou super padam caf
bien faire quoi c'est pas mal la dame ce
touriste 5
jordan des cadrages les touristes en
quête tam cette tour f 1 tour 8
ça l'a plutôt pour les saboter gérant
l'impression que tu aurais fait arrêter
une faute est ce possible
elle va devoir ramener à tour avec trois
finalement probablement pour protéger
soit l'une va plutôt celle 5
mais il aura perdu un tempo topalov le
schéma qu'on pensait qu'ils étaient
normales pour lui mais du coup y'a un
truc qui donne embêté dans ce set up
s'il n'a pas fait de battre n'y a que
lui qui le sait
bizarre donc
on va voir mais tout reste un axe paraît
logique 1 pour chasser cette dame
bah en fait oui tu peux pas supporter le
clouage soissons donc sinon on quoi
faire dame f2 bon ok être possible mais
est à son tour celui tout ça me plairait
pas les seuls à manger 5 et 2 passes et
la dame rêve enfin ouais je sais
tellement envie d'avoir la tour par là
en réalité
étrange écoute ça lui a bike 13 vous
disséminés autour c'est un échec de bas
mais bon allez voir on va aller jeter un
oeil on a un peu de partout fab plus
bassement suis un peu ya plein de portes
en même temps c'est le torcéen d'accord
possible de prendre j'imagine parce que
dame proches de mgr sarr extrait mignon
et du coup va y a pas pris bon c'est
tellement bizarre qu'en position c'est
dur de donner un jugement mais non mais
ceux d'autres facilitant 10 c'est bien
pour les blancs et en plus sus
matériellement c'est bien quand même
devant s contre la tour ont juste un
pion ce serait un retour de manivelle à
se mériter
si on voit vraiment tout
disney plouagat fait aussi ba écoute qui
a fait de la mef de écoute écoute s'il
voulait pas jouer avec touré froid de
toute façon il n'avait plus trop de
choix après un nom mais ok ça va tu dois
te traite des clouères donc on est dix
dans des cas cette option d'un f2 tu me
la donne quelque part quand même topalov
qui est pas réputé pour être un bon
joueur de rapides un même l' inverse
c'est pas un bon c'est pas bon joueur de
blitz non plus un joueur qu'il ya plus
besoin de temps pour calculer et en plus
ils calculent moins vite qu'avant donc
c'est peut-être de 2 to le tout le grand
duché source est le joueur le moins fort
de tout le grand de gestion de tout le
grand prix fina su à force d'avoir une
chose à gauche une chose à droite on se
rappelle plus mais mais c'est peut-être
le joueur le moins fort de du tableau en
rapide ici à fab bas peut-être passé
clairement et ça jamais tes sacs
annoncerait n'a jamais été bon et rapide
cavaliers 5 de max était numéro un
mondial en fait un rapide il ya les
raccords quand il avait joué à monaco
quoi c'était c'était poussif temps qu'il
a il a fait h 4 % rock et adam le sedum
de l'échiquier et met la dame en g3 est
peut-être kaliev 5 et faire des trucs
comme ça bon ok il tente un truc taipei
hau pas idiot peyo et pogab hunter
données pouvant et on y retourne on
retourne le voir quand il ya un partout
là il est où le dépôt le faire dame j'ai
trois quarts et des f-5 quelque chose
comme ça
année peau courage c'est un peu leur
reprise
bailly complètement raide en fait je
sais pas ça pas l'air terrible mais
attention ça il ya beaucoup de couleurs
opposées la loi aux fraises ça pue quoi
mais bon chaque fois qu'on va arrêter sa
position est absente sa pub on sait pas
en fait et l'autre du coup bas mais
c'est la même chose
d'après là bas il est reparti à tour
c'est non non non je n'y arrive pas qu
il ait tour c'est un x est un bon peu
importe pour ton sur maxime mais c'est
fou quand même pas des poux et bavay
c'est c'est que ces montagnes russes
quoi j'ai ici joué par maxime ok bon je
peux comprendre tu bloques un peu le
faut bien
il va faire acheter incarne toute façon
soit maintenant sont quelques coups mais
c'est sûr ce sera une suite logique de
jeu du match 5 d'envoyer pas mais on
sent on sent dans sans maxime il mérite
vraiment dalo candidat phare est quand
même bien au dessus des 2 autres un peu
plus régulier oui il fatigué juste
globalement il est plus en contrôle sur
la saison plus régulier mais le truc
c'est que fait le président sur un
tournoi pas sur ce tournoi donc la boîte
meilleur dans l'ensemble fait bon s'y
compte c'est ce qui se passe là c'est
vrai aussi sécurisé qui dit une épaule a
l'impression de pouvoir gagner et perdre
contre tout le monde emma mais aussi ça
la différence
d'ailleurs les deux ont gagné un grand
prix sont faits d'une au premier tour
d'un autre on se montre de tout faire
mais normalement vu qu'on joue trois
tournois six ans et
aider la régularité quoi quand même donc
c'est pour ça que mon max quand même
s'attendre à un blanc seing oui moi j'y
crois vraiment que je pense qu'il est
grand favori pour ce qualifier à l'issue
de tout ça mais mais oui on n'est jamais
à l'abri
tu as beau faire ça ce que des
statistiques entre entre en quelque
sorte un téléphone qui sonne une pièce
qui ripe méthode ruiz n'ont remarqué par
les arbitres je sais pas ce qu'est un
des cadres qui n'a pas joué à cinq mois
les deux groupes avaient fait aussi vu
sur f5 pouvoir chasser le cavalier est
joué pour la case de 6
je pensais ça sent l'idée c'est pas mal
joué est-ce que d'hommes b6 b3 qui est
le cas pas possible à cheval sur d'un v6
jaffer b3 même c'est juste une question
j'ai fait un bel arrêt 6b 3,4
je vais tu va échanger et si d'un bush
qui jettera ça va être géré bien là
dedans quand bascula je veux stable quoi
tu couvres les cases blanches
il n'a pas de foot cases noires très
bien je kiffe 5me sillage cinq mois tu
défends tous non je pense que c'est très
solide
est-ce que vous avez quelqu'un qui croit
encore de ce fait sur la méthode ruiz
oui bien sûr est le dernier français
calcio candidats ça devait être etienne
bacrot mais il y avait sept joueurs à
l'époque et ils tiennent avait perdu au
premier tour
c'est un jeune comme ce qui je crois
bien maxime qui a fait f5 quand même et
donc une avance plus que dix secondes ça
va bien se passer je refais un petit
tour rapide bien se passer
non mais j'ai fait ce truc
ils perdraient contre plein de joueurs
mais là je ne sais pas parce que il ya
cependant encore moins de deux minutes
et bon ok pas ces choses mais c'est
loupé à propre quoi s'est jamais propre
emma mais je crois que il ya quoi bien
défendu c'est tout mais complètement
taré
bon après maxime c'est pas non plus le
jour le plus propre du circuit en terme
d'heures plus déjà mais je leur parlais
que hungry tchouk par exemple un ding un
caruana mais bon tous ces mecs là sont
déjà aux candidats on va dire qu
candidate a quand même des joueurs plus
stable que maxime plus régulier je pense
que ding et des douches ding et caruana
ils sont quand même plus plus stable
encore que maxime notamment qu'ils
soient plus de 2800 et numéros 2 et 3
mondiaux
oui et il ya une des gros tournois
padding quand même il a gagné une grande
chasse tours justement en battant maxime
il avait gagné la sinne que phil cup
caruana qui a fait premier ex-aequo de
la head of men ils font quand même des
gros résultat les deux maxime il est
dans le deuxième round quoi avec grille
tout pour moi même toit ce dernier remet
un peu dessus quand même une moto près
ils sont au dessus des gears idée née
peau des mam etc et guiry pour le coup
il fait partie du genre plus propre mais
trop propre aux autres je suis d'accord
avec toi mais je pense que
intrinsèquement gear il est peut-être
même plus fort qu'un mvl moi soit je
sais pas mais mais un truc qui va pas
dans son jeu et un truc qui va pas non
maxime commencent à prendre le dessus
j'ai l'impression il a bien placé ses
pièces
les taux peuvent fait pas du tout
arriver attaque a eu droit qu'à un pas
du tout du tout d'ailleurs s'est plus
agi quatre radars fréquents tu vois ça
mais bon je métrages 3 me prendre kg 4
un jour offert à troy b4 maintenant
ouais enfin ça c'est longtemps qu'on le
dit et il est loin de le faire j'essaye
façon il est obligé de partir pour ça
non car angers 4 une tour en 3 et puis
va abandonner mes seins mais beaucoup
moins il en a peut être par maxime qui
aurait été en maîtrise dans cette partie
guelph on le redit que les foires sont
mieux maintenant non mais c'est pas
étonnant enfin je veux dire toujours pas
mais déjà hier la partie lente je disais
que c'était dégueulasse mais c'est un
peu ce que c'est comme ça c'est vraiment
dégueulasse qui fait défaut mais mais
bon comme j'ai dit après il faut pas
qu'ils fassent comme tu vois il tenait
un but de raccroc sur corner machin qui
une fois que le mec comme ans a bien
fallu 90 ouais c'est favola faut pas que
ça fasse ce à quoi parce qu'on sait
jamais ce qui peut arriver quand encore
les mecs ont de la réussite après ça
peut les chauffer peut se mettre à bien
jouer à son épouse au prochain sommet du
g20 des douilles trop-plein savais pas
si ça va au départage qui vaut mieux que
ce soient ceux qui se qualifient
mais à 6 6 sinon je sais pas ce que
cinéma ça va être chaud et il ya qu à
qui la faute ils convertissent
bon alors on se doit de faire si
l'aluminium à l'abandon c'est génial
quand même et il a été lent mauvais
physiquement sexuellement du bas il
s'est fait défoncer 1
incroyable mauvais choix mais n'est pas
aussi mauvais choix avons trouvé qu'il
le paye pas mais très mauvais choix je
peux pas dire autre chose je veux pas
que analyser la rejeta brut pour faire
un compte rendu en photo un jeune homme
avait le choix
topal où l'aca s'est bougé à 3 kg
quartier praille f5 et envoyer une pièce
pourquoi pas attention au keeper d'eau
qui va ce nul c'est la même chose je
sais pas prise à une pièce en fait
arrivé ici il attaque la dame et attaque
le cavalier sur d'alger cette saison de
faire ton j'ai cinq cavaliers et du coup
je gagne c'est tout de suite finir et 3
bougez pas bouger n'importe où c'est
juste une pièce de plus c'est fini bon
c'était de faire un roman monnaies tout
ça oui et après topaloff
c'est vrai qu'en rapide c'est pas bon on
a pas mais on n'a pas des moindres non
non on n'a pas brillé comme je disais je
réussis même plus peur d'un galfond
d'houdain yacco en rapide valeria quoi
et failli éliminer maxima non mais
galfond de gaz pour nous très bien mais
il est lent et je pense soit et de même
truc quand maxime pas vu rappeler les
positions qu'il est con on est peut-être
déjà conseillé mais en fait le fait
d'être lancé lessard et finit par
ailleurs à la fff si ce très joli mais
nous sommes bien qu'ils réapprennent
quoi pas donc dépôts va même gagné 2 0
ouais bon sens contre le cours du jeu et
me voilà on m'a but en contre
charpin qui que de bonnes nouvelles
aujourd'hui bas ça dépend si ma mère
fait pas éliminé bon truc à maxime a été
tranquille maxime est passé enfin au
quesnoy
on va attendre c'est officiel mais n'ont
quasi et c'est tout ce qui compte
bien sûr voir ce qu'ils font important
n'est pas bien de gagner et donc n'est
pas qualifié
et maxime après cavaliers avec deux
échecs qu'il a bien évidemment vu
puisque c'est un peu le seul coup pour
sauver le cavalier qui va être qualifié
aussi et donc mam et qui nous semble
être le joueur dangereux finalement tu
vas peut-être celui qui va qui va passer
à la trappe on verra fab
on va aller sur la fin de sa partie
quand même à la suite de celle ci c'est
un mec d'anjou est évidemment mais il
est aussi dangereux pour lui-même comme
menace et un danger pour tout le monde
est là tranquilles eux je capte pas quoi
de ce fait l'italienne tellement de
manières de jouer un truc quasi égale un
léger désavantage mais bon ça demande de
gros efforts rapportent battre maxime
café car aliev de pétards une
proposition de null null ou pattaya
rival en dix minutes a dénoncé toute la
partie dans son auto tendance voyant dry
qui ne peuvent s'expliquer au sénat va
d'abord howard p ça va continuer ça a
continué et aguerris du come on a parlé
continuera peut-être aussi tout continue
max ce que ce feeling tags
texte rend 10 minutes mais il y aura pas
d égalisation s'il se fait éliminer
c'est une autoroute pour mvl pour les
candidats pas encore parce que il suffit
qu enfin une bonne nouvelle en soi mais
c'est pas fini pour autant du tout du
tout ce sera pas ce sera pas ce ne sera
pas gagné
maxime qui a fait rage 2 me trifi a fait
3-2 et maxime bakiev peut-être l'adamant
h6 comme on le prédisait pour un f6 ou
n'importe où enfin c'est juste une pièce
de plus un tel écart a lieu quatre qui
vont rodez il ya tout qui va arriver
ils sont déjà sous bassins dépend mais
il est fort ce haut mais des fois il
fait un peu moins bien il prend pas de
risque mais lille son rush il ya deux
ans et il peut toujours avoir un de ces
jours je sais pas donc c'est un très bon
joueur plus que je le classerait avec
les grès de choquer maxime quoi ouais si
c'est vrai que tu as raison si si je
vais en mettre un dans ce groupe là ce
serait plutôt sauvé jeu tout à fait
d'accord avec toi qui pourrait remonter
un we be même pas du siba enfin il est
dû perdre une 30 40 points elo donc
c'est beaucoup à ce niveau là mais c'est
rien c'est à plus de 27 60 ouais du coup
au prochain tour contre nepos ça va être
ça va être un beau match
ouais mais ça excite maxime se qualifie
ça ça va faire du bien s'il va en demi
il est il est très très bien ouais gros
souffle et enfin on pourra quand même
commencé à souffler surtout si mam et
n'est plus dans le tournoi
oui poteau non mais là quand je vois ça
il devrait de plus être là forcément
longtemps que je sais pas
très mal quand il y aura six là il n'a
pas un échec
c'est pas facile quoi je donne des sacs
qu'il veut il fait grave une menace
discrète sera surtout rageux à faire
tourner ici c'est pour éviter le match
sûrement tu me donnes conviennent
pourcentage d'armes acquiesça 1%
le grand truc mais je sais pas aller 1-3
on a très peu de chances à zéro non plus
mais bon t'as et maxime à gagner un
maximum vient de gagner on avait un
petit peu quitté après damas six donc ça
fait 2 0 pour mac ceci s'est passé on va
encore suivre un peu la partie
yakou mais il ya comme à mes plus beaux
mecs sont drôles et impérial dans se
départagent tu mettes une toute petite
pub pour ceux qui sont pas à ça ben tant
pis 1,1 à l'ope
allez hop donc pour ceux qui sont seuls
on continue fabas à regarder
tranquillement donc tout rejet et 600
prend un pion g3 ouais ça cesse comment
à sept tours a probablement fab pour
pour venir derrière le pion paraît
logique
ça probablement continuer comme ça non
je vais bien l'option partir en a sept
tours un procès dollar était un peu un
peu et c'est un gars qui fait n'hésite
pas à mettre plein de peut-être plein de
mvele dans le chat on n'a pas fait ça dm
veine dans le chat de partout à présent
et qu'on n'a pas trop vibrer parce que
c'était presque trop facile en femme
ouais on va l'avoir partie je pense que
la ville en trois minutes à la fin sa
pendule à vingt-et-une donc anti havrais
donc en fait c'était un revers de la
main et la seconde bombe je m'étais trop
mal enfin le tepa guest est plus discuté
mais il ya plein de monde a su à0 là on
est très mal bâti légaliser c'est très
bien ça y était plus fort il l'a montré
et il a bien géré il ya rien à dire quoi
toujours évident tout le mérite en
revient à maxime puisque top up ce qu'on
dit et passent à grande cadence mais bon
il ya battu un accord rapide à riga par
exemple donc pas rigueur à riga donc
c'est toujours bien quand même capable
vous faut l'éliminer quoi j'aurais pas
pris la partie contre mac en exemple
mais mais oui fokam éliminés non je suis
d'accord avec toi c'est pas mais bon
bois trop faux sur trois thoniers quoi
enfin c'est plus un hasard org vous êtes
un athlète et l'autre vont un peu moins
c'est vrai mais il y en a un qui a été
champion du monde
ouais faut pas pour moi quand même été
officiellement officiellement il a été
donc sociologue max a gagné 2 euros
voilà il fait dames 4 c'est bien joué de
la part de guy éliminer les preuves chez
porsche on va aller voir ouais c'est ça
arrive lancé exactement ce qu'on avait
deux nuls dans les parties lentes et al
pas de chance je pense c'est vraiment
pas de chance
donc dire éliminer c'est pour ça aussi
quand on parlait quand on a parlé au
début des tournois que tableau difficile
pour moi mais avec un gi qui se profile
en demie non mais mam et a tout ce qu'il
faut en feutre et d'un bon tableau après
ça dépend de lui aussi mais si par
contre il ya qu à dieu quoi la scala été
volés sur enfer dame prend fou prend
tout reprend mais le problème c'est
qu'il aura pas le temps de manger à 7 ce
qui arrive deux élus contre attaque la
tour donc je pense qu'il va abandonner
ma maison mais il menace la dame est et
sur demande évite de madame 5 et précis
site web à bout d'homme évite aussi que
la justice d'albi oui du pointu menaces
là tu menaces
ben écoute c'est la fin bah c'est la fin
enfin pas complètement mais bon à dire
sa partie mais après mam et du coup il
ya un partout où il peut encore gagner
le match mais je suis va jouer sa
semaine aux noms mais de cette partie là
est la fin je sais juste pas la faute du
match mais ce qui la joue encore un
petit peu
bon je pas dû faire ce qu'il veut j'ai
fait dam des 8es non je pense qu'on me
demande pourquoi pas champion du monde
non mais c'est juste que vous faites je
suis concernant les champions du monde
classique d'échec donc ceux qui ont
gagné avec les matches dits donc le gie
en pleine stream en fait un recompte
kasparov par le management cramique pas
un c'est compliqué mais à cette époque
il ya deux titres décernés en même temps
ça conservateur 93 quand t'es sport a
fait scission avec la fidh et qui il a
joué son match contre short voyez ça le
piège et donc les deux champions du
monde en même temps
kasparov et karpov mais bon karpov en
fait tilter chante pas vraiment je me
suis enfin vous pouvez le mettre dans
les manuels si vous voulez il a des
champions du monde entre 75 et 84 ça y'a
rien à dire il a battu deux fois car je
croyais en match etc
mais après en fait quand il regagne le
titre compte imap 93 c'est pas vraiment
le vrai match de coupe du monde donc
mais des lignes et pour moi les simples
que ces casses par kasparov qui arrivent
comme cramique hyper bon match en ligue
des champions du monde indique défendent
titre contre les koversada karo kann
puis krainik juin 20 h 30 au palace en
2006 la sphère du watergate de votre
organisme toilettes gates etc topalov
machin là ok il gagne le match il garde
son titre d' octobre l'offre en fait n'a
pas gagné ce match soit champion du
monde et puis après avec raven il perd
contre attendre un an de champion du
monde un nombre pair 34 san carlos de
champion du monde
essai tout fait mais ya pas de qualif
man il n'y a pas de karpov base des 90
et pas de ya pas de case dit mais il n'y
a pas de topalov pour moi ma fille avec
un jour un tournoi assez fort saint
louis ce qui était quand même
ah mais non mais je suis d'accord mais
ce n'est pas guy le match le truc
c'était en fait pour le saint louis
c'est une sorte de candidats au permis
clés au nom des gens je crois qu'il y
avait joué je crois qu'il est tout le
monde à san luis
mais peu importe voilà ça c'est juste ma
vision chacun d'art comme une envie et
donc c'est gagné pour yacco donc qui a
co qui va amener mamediarov dans des
nouveaux départage on va jeter un oeil à
andreikin andré kim qui est en train de
craquer d'après d'après le chat est
d'après leur dis aussi apprennent aux
yeux aussi d'ailleurs mais là
apparemment valence cf
ça va craquage la position est très
compliqué ce conte chacun pour les
éléphants ont pris je préfère réseaux
secs les noirs clairement m'apprendre
équine qui est un sacré client en blitz
est en rapide
c'est chaud n'est pas coûteux
ce que je conteste pas ce qui a été
numéro un mondial ça c'est vrai reste à
voir quand même assez extraordinaire
topalov no 1 mondial son veut pas lui
enlever pas 10h10 son titre qui
officiellement il l'a en fait un maire
c'est juste pour moi que je considère
pas comme tel quoi donc
comment est-ce qu'il va continuer dans
sa une partie qui nous intéresse
complètement fable puisque je traverse
au maximum ses fonctionnaires faire de
vagues si l'on préférait quand même voir
t'attendrai qui n'a fab alors que
maintenant alors didonne +3 à andré
keane donc apparemment c vhc qui a
craqué weedon et ab3 c'est vraiment
logique la tat que la tourte attaque le
6 et tu vas prendre sur échec donc qui
sembleraient semblerait qu'on puisse
qu'on puisse voir au contraire une
qualification d'ordre équine fab
c'est mieux ce qui serait mieux et la
partie s'est retournée en l'espace de
dix secondes le temps de dire de bohain
ben bernanke est complètement perdant
alors avoir risque d'am-dam beffroi va
être joué c'est vrai que la praline
l'ordi c'est le coup le plus logique le
plus en f2 et défendu on couvre les
cases aller dimitri mais bon ce sera pas
un cadeau dimitri dans le sens où il va
être
il peut être très pénible en rapide
dimitri we battent comme l'italie en
finale de couler en 2013 ouais donc c
est ni l'un ni l'autre n'est ni un
cadeau est on est on est pour la nulle
pour qu'il se fatigue un maximum au
final en tout cas là on a on a on alors
dit qu'il bloque un peu il ya eu
beaucoup de coups de jouer il a joué
quoi 3 g 8 g dames b3 dame eu quatre
échecs fouet trois ya beaucoup de
virages et encaissé cavaliers les
longues et il à +6 vraiment de breaking
rejoindre match alors andré king qui
pourrait rejoindre max effectivement bon
c'est pas encore fini fini mais bon là
il a comme une pièce est une pièce un
pion de plus et le roi va pouvoir
repartir en géant il va être
complètement protégé semble que le
joueur russe qui est qui est remplaçant
au pied levé
fab oui oui bah écoute il à faire son
petit tournoi et il va mettre un terme
aux espoirs de vote est avec moi qui
n'avait pas énormément mais qui pouvait
clairement quand même prétendre on sait
pas et là il prétend plus rien du tout
il ne prétend plus on va laisser à la
bride de coûts arrivée qui devrait être
la dernière à mon avis cette partie va
pas durer énormément de temps on dit
bonne nouvelle ou ouais ça doit plutôt
être une bonne nouvelle même si on a
fait de bonnes nouvelles
c'est pas en fait que je trouve moins
fort que je sais que fondamentalement
mais c'est gauche de sexe c'est pas
genre qui a aussi un maxime je pense que
maxime n'a jamais battu on bat ok tu vas
parti longtemps fait alors qu'andré
keane suis sûr qu'il va pouvoir lui
planter un truc en prévenant en
attendant l'ouverture abri qui nie les
malpris pas faim oui des 4 x 4 des cas
de fuji 5 m3 machin
il cherche pas à faire avant l'ouverture
on guette les blancs sera dur de le
planter mais andry qui noir tu vois ça
être une sorte de karo kann une petite
vente de 80 et comme un truc où maxime
peut juste gagné sans jouer je pense
pareil que toi un peu comme un peu à
l'image du match d'aujourd'hui seigneur
et à résidence parce que je sais c'est
qu'en fait est bien préparé il était
seconds hand and andile jali c'est ce
qui fait quoi donc en fait en valeur
intrinsèque montrer qu'il n'est pas
moins bien mais par rapport au match
contre maxime c'est vrai que ce sera
vrai un vrai problème pour pour le
joueur russe
on va voir comment comment ça se termine
alors il a quand même réussi à créer une
menace ou pas et non sur damas dame f1
se soignera roi ou trois fous ces cinq
rir poster d'or reprendre au second dans
la pendule
il va faire quelques petits échecs ici
et là il va la finir va on va suivre
cette élimination directe après nous on
se quittera afab évolue bien sûr puis on
se retrouve demain du coup pour pour le
match de maxi voir sur mon compte rendre
eakin ça vous pourrez vous dire ou alors
ça va voir le vrai on dit andré kinji
gayant cli de mvl
pense aussi que ça devrait bien se
passer mais bon non mais moi c'est pas
clair mais c'est juste un bon
apparemment voilà il n'y a pas à se
plaindre de jouer deux jours de week-end
bien sûr que non bien sûr que non
les mecs vont assez pour l'église de mam
et non pas non mais on va on va laisser
ma mais faire faire ses beats et surtout
que c'est pas en fait on s'en fiche
maxime bonjour allemand oui enfin oui
peut-être un jour oui mais là ça va pas
le qualifier ou l'éliminer pour autant
jamais fait sa vie maxime est passé
c'est ça qui est cool
ouais on reviendra on reviendra demain
on fait tout le tournoi en direct donc
on garde un peu de andré qui d'un zéro
officiers à louey officiel ok bon roy
keane donc futur adversaire de max donc
c'est pas mal pour maxime mais ce sera
sarko regarde quand même quoi que je
classerais d'un niveau de iakovenko un
truc comme ça donc pas fait mais maxime
plus forme
paris les plus forts clairement
clairement maxime plus fort je le mets
une petite pub fab
histoire de faire les petites minutes de
plus avant de faire la conclusion donc
va à l'essai à on va laisser tourner
donc vraie belle journée belle journée
ce qui reste encore quelque chose qui
joue dans navarro en ga au sahara fait
nul du coup on écoute ce qu'on a pour
l'instant de claire pour pour l'épauler
pour les quarts de finale
c'est quoi c'est
pata maxime contre andré keane tanner
poço fundo moitié de tableau de chasse
est très clair c'est très classe et
l'autre moitié
j'ai passé que tu racontes cariat qui
noierait krishna on sait pas et ben on
sait rien gil bong haruna va répondre
mam et où il reste trois matchs en fait
c'est tout dans l'autre moitié de
tableau
ouais la mater table de maxime tout est
clair les maximes
maxime qui encore plus favoris avant le
tournoi pour pour pour aller aux
candidats la petit à petit ouais ouais
bah c'est bien pour enfin lui il a passé
son tour les eaux n'ont pas pris de
point de bonus à par sow donc je dire de
base on aurait signé pour ça avant le
tour oui mais voilà puis l'a d'ailleurs
mamie pas encore sorti d'affaires donc
on verra dans la réponse un peu plus
tard dans la journée quoi on a lui dit
y'a rien à king ce soir et dans les
arénas king ça reprend mais ça reprend
dans cinq points tuer pendant cinq mois
tu vas plus en avoir tu auras de la prod
chez slick après mais tu auras plus de
plus d'arena c'était le truc qui
marchait bien donc bon c'est bon
forcément enlevé ouais on sait où on va
on va mettre plus d'argent pour faire
autre chose tant mais la prod classique
ce sera sympa mais c'est un petit peu
dommage
les arénas ça plaisait à plein de monde
en fait c'est juste marrant c'est juste
marrant que ce soit le truc qu'ils aient
qu'ils aient enlevé dans tout ce qui à
quoi mais tu as un championnat du monde
de de peser alors juste un tas de trucs
en fait très bizarre de jouer ce match
enfin il peut nager c'est de me
qualifier juste comme ça pour rire mais
j'ai pas trop envie de jouer enfin
faisant rage sur le pain moi
personnellement fâché que les gens
aiment beaucoup moi perso j'aime pas du
tout enfin au début un peu oui enfin
palmarès j'en ai fait 15 et puis oui ça
veut dire ça m'a saoulé enfin non j'ai
joué une heure dans ma vie puis après ça
je comprends juste pas l'intérêt en fait
c'est le face à mu en fait d'en faire
trois mais déjà au troisième journée
marc passé j'ai passé pas mon délire a
prêché que les gens adorent et même je
le recommande pour les gens qui veulent
progresser de denfert parce que ça
permet de de s'affûter l'oeil à devoir
vite mais non moi je peux faire
tellement faire une vraie partie
d'échecs patois hocine enfin un peu
d'allant je t'ai jamais vu bon je joue
je fais pas de bile sur internet on
plonge donc en fait
moi c'est spécial qu'on va dire mais
leur âge photophone mais oui enfin ce
cas mieux de josé check contre quelqu'un
ou rec je vais attendre un bus plus de
faire des parties de faire des arénas de
faire des trucs comme ça que de résoudre
des puzzles en fait ça me saoule très
vite
ah ouais je rappelle aussi que les
leçons de choses comme sont sortis en
france et donc pour ceux qui peuvent
être intéressés vous savez vous pouvez
prendre les abonnements
j'ai déjà mondialement vous pouvez déjà
les voir donner de vos retours
et puis ben les autres s'ils voulaient
tester vous pouvez essayer ambitions
ouais donc comme c'est notre cadence
ferrée plutôt le rapide par 20 minutes
par là c'est pas mal 15 15 20 en
tournant à jeudi repas sur l'internet où
le but je me sens va être bon sur ces
belles paroles sages fab
je propose qu'on se quitte qu'on aille
faire le petit résumé de la partie de
maxime et puis on se retrouve demain à
14 heures pour un match qui pourrait
qualifier maxime cette fois ci un
vraiment aux candidats le match suivant
pourrait déjà être décisif dans la
qualification
non monsieur on vous souhaite à tous une
excellente après-midi mois de façon je
recevrai ce soir parce que c'est le
vendredi et puis samedi 14h donc demain
on se retrouve pour le prochain tour
merci à tous merci fab auto ciao